Guten Abend.
Jetzt nicht schon am Anfang übertreiben, wir brauchen euch nachher noch laut.
Wir haben noch viel vor.
Richtig. Und wir sagen herzlich willkommen in Frankfurt am Main, den Podcast kennt ihr soweit. Vielleicht auch dieses Intro. Beim letzten Mal habe ich auch gefragt, wer hat schon mal in einfacher Geschwindigkeit gehört? Das kann jetzt jeder nochmal selber testen, ob man es wiedererkennt.
Hallo Stefan.
Hallo Wolfgang. Und es ist schon wahnsinnig langsam, oder? Wer hat sich jetzt gewundert und dachte, das ist das Intro? Wer hört uns normalerweise in höherer Geschwindigkeit als 1,0?
Es geht.
Der Rest 1,0?
Möchte es auskosten.
Okay. Verstehe ich nicht, aber gut.
Für die anderen wird es ja eher ein Problem sein, wenn wir jetzt in unendlicher Langsamkeit heute sprechen im Vergleich zu dem, was man zu Hause hören kann, für die diese Live-Salon dann im Nachhinein hören, die können natürlich die Geschwindigkeit nach oben pushen.
So ist es. So, wir fangen an mit einem kleinen Joke, denn ihr kennt Wolfgang natürlich nicht nur von Wohlstand für alle auch, sondern auch aus der Filmanalyse. Ich lese die Filme vor, die als Trailer beim Superball in der Werbung liefen und nenne danach den Titel, der den Best Film Oscar gewonnen hat. Und dann überlegen wir schon während ich vorlese, fällt uns da irgendwas auf? Oder muss man das noch kommentieren? Es könnte auch sein, dass man es gar nicht mehr kommentieren muss. Also Filmtrailer, die liefen. Guardians of the Galaxy 3, The Flash, Fast and Furious 10, Transformers 7, Scream 6, Indiana Jones 5, Creed 3, Super Mario Bros. Movie, Dungeons and Dragons, irgendwas mit einem Untertitel. Und jetzt ein bisschen außer der Reihe wahrscheinlich. 65. Ich erkläre kurz, worum es geht. Adam Driver.
Adam Driver läuft mit einem Mädchen durch die Gegend.
Adam Driver, bekannt als Kylo Ren aus dem Star Wars Universum, stürzt mit einem Raumschiff auf einem Planeten ab, auf dem Saurier leben.
Ja, aber im Prinzip ist es dann von der Dramaturgie ähnlich wie die Serie Last of Us und die braucht neun Stunden statt 90 Minuten.
Genau, das kann zum Beispiel sein. Und dann letzter Film, und ich habe jetzt nichts ausgelassen oder so, sondern das ist die Reihenfolge, wie sie liefen. Und jetzt der letzte Film, Er counting a legend mit Matt Damon und Ben Affleck, die nochmal über die Basketball-Sneaker, Michael Jorr, Er und so weiter. So, das war die Liste und jetzt kommt der beste Film, Everything Everywhere All at Once. Was fällt uns da auf?
Wahrscheinlich, dass es sich da nicht um eine Fortsetzung handelt, könnte geholfen haben. Es fällt auf, dass dieser Film schon im Titel verspricht, wir beinhalten eh alles. Ihr könnt euch die anderen Filme schenken.
Und wir kennen die alle schon.
Und wir kennen die alle auch schon, ja. Also wir haben ja eigentlich ein multiversums Film dort und zugleich haben wir diese Franchise-Universen, die das Kino immer mehr bevölkern. Und es ist wirklich absurd, wie man jetzt tatsächlich es geschafft hat, auch rein zu etablieren, an die ich niemals gedacht hätte. Also man versucht auch gar nicht mehr rein zu beginnen zu lassen, sondern man versucht nur ganz lose noch irgendwas anzuknüpfen. Also beispielsweise diese Creed-Nummer, dass man da jetzt den dritten Teil hat. Das ist ja ein Film, der mal damit begann, dass man sagte, gut, wir haben Rocky völlig durchgespielt und ich möchte aber sagen, ich bin großer Rocky-Fan. Und dann sagt man aber, jetzt könnte ja Rocky auch noch mal einen Jungen unterrichten und der wiederum muss dann kämpfen gegen und dann können wir noch mal alte Figuren auftauchen lassen. Und deren Söhne. Und der hat auch wieder Söhne. Und dann war auch Brigitte Nielsen, konnte sich auch noch mal 100.000 Euro verdienen. Das ist schon gigantisch, dass es aber funktioniert. Also man kann es etablieren, wenn gleich bei manchen Filmen überhaupt nicht mehr die Frage ist, sind sie erfolgreich, weil sie irgendeine Reihe sind oder sind sie erfolgreich, weil auf TikTok gerade irgendwas viral geht. Man muss zu diesem oder jedem Film und dann Randale machen.
So, damit ist...
Ich habe jetzt noch nicht erlebt.
Du hast ja auch dazu aufgerufen, nicht zu machen, deswegen haben die Leute auf dich gehört und haben im Kino nicht Randalliert. Gut, wir dachten uns, es sind ja aufregende Zeiten, ihr habt ja alles mitbekommen. Chi ist zum Beispiel gerade bei Putin für mehrere Tage. In Amerika stürzen irgendwelche Drohnen ab, weil irgendwer irgendwen kollidiert. In Berlin ist ein Bildungsgipfel und es kommt dabei, geht niemand hin. Also 14 von 16 Bildungsministern gehen gar nicht hin. Und Leute solche Sachen, Randale im Kino, also es geht drunter und drüber. Und wir wollen uns alle damit beruhigen, dass wir uns jetzt das grusamste Thema überhaupt nehmen, thematisch aufgeworfen, einfach eine totale Stabilität über Generationen, Menschenleben hinweg. Und dieses Thema lautet der Mond. Ist er aufgegangen? Ich verspreche, das war die einzige Animation, aber die wollte ich nicht verkneifen. Also der Mond. Was für Streitthemen könnte es eigentlich beim Thema Mond geben? Ein paar sind ja abgeräumt, waren wir da und so weiter, wissen wir nicht genau. Aber der Mond als ultimative Konstante ist, und dem nähern wir uns langsam, jetzt in Bedrängnis gekommen. Denn wir können uns auch auf den Mond nicht mehr verlassen. Wir wollen in die ganze moderne Welt einsteigen. Mit dieser Nachricht, vielleicht hat es jemand gehört, oder hat sogar schon so ein neues Samsung-Gerät, da zuckte eine Hand ein Galaxy S23.
Jetzt musst du erklären, was das kann.
Dieses Handy fotografiert den Mond mit dem kleinen Unterschied. Es ist dann gar nicht der Mond, der auf dem Bild erscheint, denn wie hier steht, es ist mal wieder Mond und Fake in einem Aufwasch nachrichtlich zu behandeln gewesen. Und wir nähern uns mal diesem kleinen Problem, denn es ist wirklich wahnsinnig amüsant. Also ein Handy wird vorgestellt und Leute untersuchen, was hat es denn damit sich auf. Und The Verge, also eine sehr große Publikation, greift das auf und beruft sich selber hier auf eine Publikation bei Reddit, ein User iBreakPhotos hat herausgefunden, nicht mal den Mond kann man einfach so fotografieren, da muss unbedingt noch ein künstliches Intelligenz, irgendwas Large-Language-Model und so weiter, um den Mond zu fotografieren. Und bei The Verge haben sie sich wie folgt darüber lustig gemacht. Und es ist, wie soll man sagen, wer von euch hat einen GPT-Account?
Macht großen Spaß, finde ich.
Wer hat mit 3.5 schon rumgespielt und so, aber wer bezahlt jetzt wirklich Geld für eine Vierer-Version?
Also niemand. Doch eine Person braucht es wahrscheinlich beruflich. Ja, wird bestätigt und sonst sind aber schon ein paar dabei mit GPT unterwegs. Ich hatte so eine diebische Lust, mir von GPT Leute bewerten zu lassen, die ich auch nicht mag. Aber das macht GPT nicht, das finde ich so schade.
Ja, JTB hat Anstandsregeln. Müssen wir eigentlich jetzt noch mal kurz erklären, GPT und so weiter, wenn jetzt wirklich nur einer hier ist, der Geld dafür bezahlt. Ja, dann musst du mal ein paar Worte dazu sagen. Sonst nähern wir uns dem einfach langsam.
Wir haben ja schon drüber gesprochen.
Wir haben auch schon drüber gesprochen. Also es gibt jetzt, man kann jetzt so kleine Brüder, die aber elektronisch sind, mit denen kann man Gespräche führen und die antworten dann auch und so weiter. Na gut, wenn wir uns denn langsam...
Also es ist eigentlich eine sehr erweiterte Suchmaschine, nämlich in der Form, dass man nicht mehr etwas eingibt und dann anfangs auf verschiedenen Seiten, sich die Informationen zurechtzuklauben, die man braucht, sondern man kann sich erst mal einen Text verfassen lassen zu einer bestimmten Frage. Also wenn ich jetzt wissen will, inwieweit kann es sinnvoll sein, die Mehrwertsteuer zu erhöhen, welche Effekte hat das für wen, dann wird Chachiviti mir eine Antwort dazu schreiben und sich auf gewisse Statistiken und dergleichen berufen. Allerdings ist es anders als bei Google. Wir können nicht dann mal gerade in die Quellen schauen und sagen, ach so, das ist ja alles hier vom Hans-Werner-Sinn-Institut, deswegen ist das vielleicht mit Vorsicht zu genießen, sondern wir müssen das in dieser gewissen Objektivität, die es annimmt, dann so hinnehmen und können es eher schwierig hinterfragen. Aber es ermöglicht einem auch, dass man sich einfach Dinge schnell zusammenfassen lassen kann.
Wie gesagt, wir lernen, wir machen es mal heuristisch vorsichtig, nähern uns langsam. Ich habe auch zum Beispiel eben erst das Wort Ökonometrie, oder wie es heißt, gelernt. Man kann das studieren und es ist VWL mit noch mehr Mathe und so für alle, die sowas mögen. Also wir beginnen mal hier bei einer ganz einfachen Tätigkeit. Wir sind nachts draußen, der Mond, es ist romantisch, wir wollen den Moment festhalten, machen ein Foto und was passiert dann eigentlich?
Also es gab einen Redditor, ich glaube, es war iBreakphones, das ist sein Name auf Reddit, ich bin sorry, wenn ich das falsch sage. Also was sie eigentlich gemacht haben, um das zu testen, war, sie haben eine High-Res-Foto des Mondes verlaufen und dann sie habe es, denke ich, zu 170 x 170. Und dann sind sie auf der Runde und haben mit dem Samsung-Phone eine Bilder von dem Blut, die sie verlaufen haben.
Also, das ist jetzt ein ganzes Ding, wo du...
fragt Linae Pitell hier, es sind Fotografen anwesend, die gleich einen Schweiß ausbrechen. Man macht nachts Fotos vom Mond und man stellt fest, das ist ja gar nicht der Mond. Dann geht man in so eine Laborsituation, okay, stell mal den Laptop da drüben auf, zeig mal einen weißen Punkt. So, dann fotografiert man den, der Rest des Raumes ist dunkel, das Handy denkt, das ist der Mond, zack, wird der Mond da einfach rein retuschiert. Man hat also gar nicht ein Foto gemacht, sondern runtergeladen aus dem Internet, was geht denn da vor sich? Und so sieht das dann aus, also man zoomt so ein bisschen ran, Samsung ist ja sehr stolz darauf, irgendwie 69 Zoom nachts und tagsüber hundertfach und so. Und man macht ein Foto, zack, und dann plötzlich, oh, sehr hochauflösend und so weiter. Und da stellt sich nicht nur die Frage, was ist eigentlich ein Foto, sondern Assuming the moon is real. Did we land on it?
Baseline assumption, there is a moon in the sky. I don't, you know, fine. So when you look at the moon, you're almost always looking at the same thing. Well, no, it's not that. It's just like, well, you definitely took a photo of the moon. It's just your camera is better or worse. And if the camera is like, I know what you're trying to do.
Also, was ist ein Foto? Und wenn ich ein Foto habe, das mir irgendwas zeigt, lügt es. Wir kommen also in so eine Zeitschleife rein, wie eben schon bei den Filmen. Alles ist in der 17. Version. Und wir müssen uns ernsthaft die Frage stellen, wenn wir den Mond auf einem Foto sehen, ist das Foto dann echt? Und was zeigt es uns eigentlich? So, was sehen wir auf diesem Bild? Den Mond oder nicht? Wer sagt, wir sehen hier den Mond?
Ja, das ist jetzt so eine Sache. Du zeigst jetzt diese Mondlandung, bei der man ohnehin schon alle Gerüchte kennt. Und jetzt willst du auch noch wissen, jetzt soll sich hier noch jemand blamieren und sagen, ich glaube aber daran.
Also es gibt einen Anhaltspunkt, an dem man sehr gut argumentieren kann, ob das jetzt entweder A, es ist ein Foto des Mondes, oder B, nein, es ist kein Foto. Also A, wer sieht hier ein Foto des Mondes?
Oder müsste man die Frage vielleicht...
B, wer sieht denn hier ein irgendwie fabriziertes, was auch immer, was ist ein Foto, was ist eine Lüge? Wer glaubt nicht, dass wir hier den echten Mond fotografiert sehen, sondern irgendwie anders hergestellt?
Und müsste man nicht die Frage auch noch stellen, inwieweit man glaubt, dass das das berühmte Foto ist?
Das kommt noch dazu, ist das eigentlich ein berühmtes Foto? Woran könnte man dann diesem Foto erkennen, dass es entweder ein richtiges Foto ist oder nicht? Ruft mal rein, wer hier einen Anhaltspunkt sieht. Die Stange, die wehende Fahne. Ja, also diese Fahne wird von zwei Seiten gehalten. Wir wissen, auf dem echten Bild ist das nicht so. Oder ist das ein echtes Foto? Ist das ein echtes Foto oder nicht? Nochmal die Frage A, das ist ein echtes Foto. B, das ist ein generiertes Bild. Okay, also hier sehen wir mal ein richtig echtes Foto. Das waren jetzt zwei Fakes und Matthias hat uns ein bisschen geholfen. Das ist die NASA-Webseite mit einem Bild von Buzz Aldrin. Und gelb hinterlegt seht ihr die Bildunterschrift, die die NASA ausgewählt hat. Also ich kann es jetzt hier nicht lesen, aber Buzz Aldrin steht auf dem Mond, neben ihm das Vehikel und so weiter und so fort. Und das hat dann Matthias bei Mid Journey eingetragen. Also einfach nur diese Bildunterschrift als Prompt. Und dann kamen diese Bilder von eben raus, was uns ja zeigt, okay, wir können also wirklich auch so fotorealistischen und wenn man genau hinschaut, ihr könnt ja die Bilder dann mal selber suchen und vergleichen. Das sind auch nicht dieselben Anzüge. Hier wurde nicht einfach reproduziert, was schon in den Datenbanken lag oder so, sondern nein, hier wurde erst gelernt, wie sieht so ein Anzug ungefähr aus? Ja, da müssen so Schläuche dran und irgendwie und so. Und dann ist das halt ein Foto vom Astronaut auf dem Mond.
Und das ist JetGPT für Bilder, wenn man so möchte.
Mid Journey ist JetGPT für Bilder. Und wir krammen es also nicht mehr so einfach wie bisher, dass wir einfach sagen, das Bild ist gefaked. Da ist nämlich ein riesiges Raumschiff drauf. Also das ist sozusagen die Michael Bay herangehensweise. Transformers 3. Und ich zeige euch hier aber nochmal, das ist wirklich ein echtes Bild vom Mond. Also ein echtes Foto, so weit wir uns gesagt wurden, das ist ein echtes Foto. Also das lässt sich so auf der NASA-Seite finden. Aber es ist eben wirklich ununterscheidbar mittlerweile von fabrizierten Bildern. Und jetzt muss Samsung das natürlich aufklären. Was machen die denn da? Muss das ja auch für nicht sein? Muss jetzt jedes Bild mit einem Mond drauf immer gleich einen Fake-Verdacht haben? Und die Erklärungs-Webseite, die nur auf Koreanisch existiert und dann auf Englisch von Google Translate übersetzt wurde, damit wir das lesen können, also der Link kommt von Samsung, das über Google zu übersetzen, lautet hier Aufklärung zum Moonshot. Und das fand ich irgendwie besonders amüsant. Was passiert also? Samsung macht Fotos und möchte gerne aus diesen Links etwas blurry Fotos rechts diesen schönen scharfen Mond machen. Also, und das ist ja die moderne Antwort, wir nehmen ein AI-Model, ziehen einfach eine rote Linie drum und sagen, ja, keine Ahnung, das ist halt so ein Modell. Wir würden sagen Black Box. Keiner kann da reinschauen, das Dokument erklärt auch nicht, was da passiert. Wir sehen halt, okay, Input. Es sind mehrere grüne Punkte, also das sind fotografierte Monde. Und dann kommen aber aus der lokalen Datenbank des Handys so sehr viele orange Monde. Und aus diesen hunderten von Fotos, die entweder gerade gemacht wurden oder schon in einer Kamera drin waren, kommt dann einfach dieser blaue Mond raus. So, und das ist dann der Output. Vielleicht, man kann es glaube ich nicht so richtig erkennen, dass es hier einen Unterschied zwischen Input und Output gibt, aber dafür braucht man jetzt auch unbedingt, ganz wichtig, künstliche Intelligenz. Und die Erklärung, man scrollt dann weiter, ja, es ist halt ein roter Kreis drum, und es ist dann einfach die Black Box. Und man stößt hier aber, und das ist wirklich interessant, an physikalische Limitierung. Also dieses Foto kann man gar nicht so fotografieren. Es gibt einfach keine Kameratechnik, mit der man diese Fotografie so machen kann, denn wir haben es mit physikalischen Grenzen zu tun, nämlich ein Mangel an Licht. Also müssen wir auf die Realität, die wir eigentlich abbilden wollen, indem wir sie aufzeichnen, etwas hinzuaddieren, das sich dann schon im Handy findet. In dem Falle ganz easy, einfach schon früher aufgenommen wurde, oder wie auch immer. Man nimmt so alte Mondbilder, baut die dann irgendwie zusammen. Und damit, und das wird heuristisch ganz kurz mühsam, aber es ist nur ein ganz kleiner Sprung, den Mond auszutauschen in der Fotografie gegen etwas anderes, was heute genauso häufig fotografiert wird wie der romantische Mond, nämlich das Gesicht. So, wir haben also bei TikTok, diese Frage könnte man ja auch stellen, okay, GPT-4, ein Account. Wer hat schon mal Bold Glamour benutzt, den TikTok-Filter? Traut euch nur einer. Nee, das glaube ich nicht. Wer kennt Bold Glamour?
Aber viele kennen sicherlich andere Filter, mit denen man das Gesicht entsprechend manipulieren kann. Aber das ist jetzt nur ein Filter, der besonders beliebt ist. Noch ein Wort zu dem Mond. Also wir erleben ja dann hier eine Simulation, die eigentlich die Realität optimiert, verbessert herstellt, so wie sie nicht ist. Es gibt ja immer wieder schon bei den Simulationstheoretikern wie Boutria oder Verrio diese Fantasie. Man möchte eine Karte von der Welt anlegen und sagt sich, eigentlich wäre die Karte am genauesten, wenn man sie so groß wie die Welt macht. Und dann ist aber irgendwann die Welt darunter verschwunden gegangen. Und das ist ja etwas, was wir jetzt hier erleben. Weil man dann auch bei Dingen wie dem Mond kaum noch sagen kann, naja, sonst gehe ich mal selbst hin und schaue nach. Das heißt, ich kann immer nur das über Bild Vermittelte sehen. Während wir ja jetzt gerade eben eine ganz eigenartige Erfahrung draußen im Foyer gemacht haben, wir begegnen Leute, die uns immer nur gesehen haben auf Bildern. Und jetzt sind sie ganz schockiert, dass wir so aussehen, wie wir aussehen. Also, großer Zuspruch aufs Publikum.
Bold Glamour ist also unbekannt, deswegen müssen wir euch das zeigen. Achtung, wir sind jetzt im TikTok-Universum, hier gibt es auch Ton. Also hier liegt nicht einfach nur ein Filter auf dem Gesicht, sondern der ganze Habitus verändert sich. Irgendwas passiert mit der ganzen Person. Es ist mehr als einfach.
TikTok arbeitet ja immer mit diesem Überraschungsmoment. Wir sehen sie jetzt hier mit ihrem Alltagsgesicht. Sie macht dann noch extra ein Doppelkinn, verbirgt es hinter der Tasse und dann kommt sie mit diesem gekletteten jungen Gesicht da raus. Und das ist ja eigentlich immer diese Komponente, die es für TikTok braucht, um eine Viralität herzuquellen, sodass man denkt, oh hätte ich ja nicht gedacht.
Ja und die Leute sind wie verzaubert von sich selbst und dem neuen Angebot, das sie der Welt machen können. Hier noch ein Beispiel, das wurde mit sehr viel Wind aufgenommen. Ich weiß nicht genau, wie viel Bass jetzt hier zu hören ist.
Oh mein Gott, ich bin wundervoll.
Aber was geschieht denn da eigentlich? Also man würde jetzt sagen, sieht jünger aus, aber es wird das Gesicht etwas verschmälert. Die Wangenknochen gehen nach oben. Die Lippen sind etwas voller. Das ist ein perfektes Make-up.
Also Samsung hat ja wenigstens für die Fotos noch so ein PDF veröffentlicht, also so ein Google übersetztes Seite, die man sich dann ausdrucken kann, wo nochmal und so. Versucht wurde, nichts darzustellen. Bei TikTok wissen wir ja gar nicht, was hier vor sich geht und das finden auch die Nutzer. Ja, was passiert genau? Also sie sieht das und kann es gar nicht glauben. Also sie kann nicht mal das Resultat so richtig pasen und versteht das recht nicht. Das macht das Handy irgendwie, wie funktioniert das und so. Trotzdem sind diesen Leuten die Anwendungsbereiche schon wohl bewusst. Also es ist scary, aber cool ist, dass man nicht mehr bezahlen muss, um auf Fotos gut auszusehen. Und da man sich ja hauptsächlich im Foto-Zeitalter, also im Handy-Zeitalter so auf Fotos gut anstellen muss, ist das ja schon mal... Man hat viel gewonnen, man muss nicht mehr entweder selber das Make-up machen oder machen lassen, sondern man macht einfach einen Knopfdruck und fertig. Ist doch egal, wie es genau passiert.
Man darf halt nur nicht rausgehen dann.
Man darf da nicht rausgehen, man ist dann an seinen Zielschap gefesselt.
Das wäre eigentlich das Konzept. Wir müssen ja an Hollywood denken, an all die Stars, die natürlich alles tun, um jung auszusehen und dann gibt es ja so Fälle wie Marlene Dietrich, die sich 15 Jahre, also den Rest ihres Lebens in ihrer Pariser Wohnung versteckt, damit sie nicht mehr gesehen wird, wie sie altert, damit das Bild von ihr ewig jung bleibt. Und das wäre eigentlich das Tool für Marlene Dietrich gewesen, einfach aus der Pariser Wohnung heraus nach wie vor tolle Fotos senden zu können, weil die App ja alles dann nivelliert, was an Alterungserscheinungen da ist.
Genau, oder man will sich nicht einsperren lassen, dann muss man raus, aber das kostet dann entweder Zeit oder Geld. Die dritte Frau hier präsentiert uns das nochmal. Ich nehme mal an, es ist sehr zeitaufwendig.
Ich versuche heute, diesen viralen Filter hier nachzuschminken.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das hübsche oder gruselig finden soll. Die Augenbrauen sind ziemlich dunkel. Softer Lidschatten hier oben und dann hier innen, glaube ich, so ein bisschen schwarz. Ich hasse das. Natürlich Mascara, aber nicht mal so viel. Ich glaube, das Allerwichtigste bei dem Make-up ist Bronze und Kontur. Da ist nämlich eine Menge drauf. Das mache ich normalerweise nie so stark. Und meine Lippen sind einfach doppelt so groß wie sonst. Das bedeutet, ich werde sie jetzt ein bisschen overlinen. Ich habe meine Lippen gerade so viel übermacht wie noch nie und es ist trotzdem noch immer nicht groß genug. Und schauen wir mal, wie echt mein Make-up jetzt aussieht.
Na ja, sie ist nicht ganz zufrieden.
Aber es klappt relativ gut.
Ja, aber sie hat auch noch einen... Also sie versteht gerade... Ach so, das ist nicht nur Farbe, das ist auch Form. Bei den Lippen okay, aber was ist mit meinen Wangenknochen und so weiter, die Jawline? Also dieser Filter macht ja viel mehr als nur Farbe. Und in der Ansicht ist das schon eine Herausforderung. Wer so aussehen will, fängt bei Make-up an und muss sich dann auch irgendwann medizinische Hilfe suchen, denn der Filter muss nachgebaut werden. Da reicht nicht nachschminken.
Es ist ja bereits in den USA so, die 18- bis 32-Jährigen machen mehr Schönheitsoperationen als alle Älteren. Und das war ja mal anders. Also das heißt, da gibt es ja schon eine sehr starke Angleichung an das, was da vorfindlich ist im Internet. Beziehungsweise, dass man sagt, man kreiert eigentlich das Gesicht, das man gerne hätte und geht dann damit hin. Es ist nicht so eine Instandsetzung, wie ja sonst Schönheitsoperationen oft angesehen wurden. Ja, so muss man sagen. Und Hildegard Knef sagte so schön, aber leider ist man bei mir mit Hacke und Beil vorgegangen. Sondern jetzt sagt man, ich habe da so ein Ideal, das kann ich mir technisch zaubern lassen. Und jetzt muss nur noch eine Ärzteschaft das in die Realität übertragen.
Genau, hier gibt das Selfie den Weg vor und man muss dann folgen.
Ja, ein uraltes Thema der Literatur. Oscar Wilde, das Bildnis des Dorian Gray. Wer es noch nicht gelesen hat, sollte es tun. Sollte sich vielleicht diesen sehr schlechten Film mit Helmut Berger ansehen. Aber Helmut Berger ist halt sehr gut, weil er der Idealtypus Dorian Gray ist. Eins der schönste Mann der Welt. Wir wissen, davon ist nichts mehr geblieben. Im Dschungelcamp konnte man sich davon überzeugen. Aber wir sehen uns mal diese Szene an. Jetzt hier Helmut Berger ist also bei einem Maler, steht Modell und sieht sich jetzt zum ersten Mal gemalt und entdeckt seine eigene Schönheit.
Offenbar hat er sich in sein eigenes Bild verliebt. Oder aber in seine eigene Schönheit, die ihm vorher nicht bewusst war. Ist es nicht ein merkwürdiger Gedanke, Dorian? In 20 Jahren, in 30 oder 40, wenn Sie ein alter hässlicher Mann geworden sind, ist er immer noch der strahlende Jüngling von heute. Das ist der Lauf der Dinge, nicht zu ändern. Was haben Sie denn, Dorian?
Warum soll ich alt werden und das da bleibt ewig jung?
Das darfst du mich nicht fragen. Ich bin Maler und kann Alchemist.
Warum kann es nicht umgekehrt sein? Warum nicht? Mein Bild wird alt, aber ich bleibe immer jung. Mein hässliches zweites Ich würde dort hängen. Und ich würde mich nie verändern.
Keine schlechte Idee. Du solltest sie patentieren lassen. Bringt jemand was?
Jeden Preis würde ich zahlen. Ich würde meine Seele geben. Wenn ich das erreichen könnte.
Und er erreicht es dann. Er verkauft seine Seele. Und dieses Bild wird immer hässlicher, immer älter. Und er selbst wird auch zu einer kalten Personer, die dann zu allem bereit ist. Aber er behält dieses strahlende Aussehen.
So und jetzt gibt es Bold Glamour. Wir haben es ja eben schon gesehen. Du hast uns Beispiele mitgebracht, wie Männer diesen Filter anwenden.
Ja, es gibt ja immer den einen Trend. Also wir haben den Filter. Und dann gibt es ganz viele Untergenres. Was denn alles damit passiert. Und es gibt zahllose Videos von Leuten, die diese App nutzen, sich dann verjüngen lassen. Und dann machen sie das so, dass man oben ihr altes Gesicht und unten ihr junges oder aufgehübschtes Gesicht sieht. Und dann fangen sie an zu weinen. Manche sagen, ich erinnere mich an meine eigene Kindheit. Andere sagen, ja so habe ich nie ausgesehen und das wollte ich immer. Und das ist etwas, was dann sehr schnell viral gegangen ist. Wir sehen uns jetzt mal ein Beispiel an.
Also er hat den Teenage-Filter benutzt und oben sieht er sich sein Dorian Gray gemalt, jung.
Genau.
Und ist ganz ergriffen von seiner eigenen Schönheit.
Ja, ich find's ja, ich weiß nicht, also ein Oscar hätte es dafür glaube ich nicht gegeben für dieses Schauspiel. Ich hab mir viele Videos angesehen und es gibt ja Leute, die können sehr gut auf Knopfdruck weinen, muss man sehr vorsichtig sein, weiß ich aus eigener Erfahrung, auf großer Distanz halten solche Leute. Aber man kann damit TikTok-Star werden und hier sehen wir noch ein weiteres Exemplar, aber jemand, der das offenbar geschaut hat.
Das ist alles, was er tut. Und es hat meinen Muskel ausgelöst.
Aber das ist super interessant, weil du hast ja eben schon gesagt, es gibt so Szenarien, wie nennt man es, nicht Herausforderungen und so, nicht Challenges, sondern Trends, aber die Subversion davon. Und das ist ja hier auch. Man ist ja so inceptionartig. Man weiß gar nicht, auf welcher Ebene der Verölkung oder noch echten Gefühlstaubiedungen man eigentlich ist. Also man muss auch sehr aufpassen, dass man nicht falsch abbiegt. Okay, das führt natürlich zu sehr viel Medienkritik, denn Journalisten wollen ja noch was zu tun haben. Wenn alle in die Bildschirme schauen, wird da Angebot gemacht. Der Spiegel hat das hier mal aufgegriffen. Bold Glamour, was gibt es dazu zu wissen und zu sagen?
Bold Glamour ist auf TikTok gerade ziemlich beliebt und wurde schon millionenfach verwendet. Das Spannende an diesem Filter ist aber, dass die Nutzer sich damit nicht einfach nur attraktiver machen wollen. Der Filter sorgt nämlich auch gerade für Diskussionen rund um Schönheitswahn und Selbstliebe. Der Bold Glamour-Filter ist ein besonders krasses Beispiel, weil er zeigt, wie gut die Technik hinter diesen Filtern schon geworden ist und weil er eben besonders krass ins Aussehen der Leute eingreift. Schaltet man den Filter nämlich aus, fühlt sich das ehrlich gesagt ziemlich enttäuschend an. Filter wie Bold Glamour zeigen einem, du wirst unsere Schönheitsideale niemals erreichen. Gleichzeitig suggerieren sie aber, andere schaffen das sehr wohl. Wenn man jetzt also wie total viele junge Menschen viel Zeit in Apps wie TikTok oder Instagram unterwegs ist, dann bekommt man eine total verzerrte Wahrnehmung davon präsentiert, wie andere aussehen und was eigentlich normal ist.
So, wir sind natürlich alle empört darüber, dass plötzlich die Leute gar keinen Maßstab dafür haben, was eigentlich normal ist und was nicht. Und das erfahren wir aber im Journalismus, wo uns natürlich seit Jahrzehnten, in dem Falle aktuell die 53-jährige Karin Mioska, die aussieht wie 25 und Ulrich Wickert mit 80 Jahren auf diesem Bild erzählen wollen, wo noch Realität vergraben ist unter diesen ganzen Medienschleiern und es ist ja nicht nur...
Aber es wird vielleicht gar nicht mehr von den Menschen so wahrgenommen. Also ich habe, ich kann es ja eingestehen, wir sind ja hier unter uns, ich war ja vor drei Wochen bei der Kosmetikerin. Ich habe aber nichts machen lassen, also nichts spritzen lassen oder so. Nein, ich habe einfach nur so eine Gesichtsreinigung gemacht und ich dachte, worüber könnte man reden? Ach ja, Madonna bei den Grammys und dann sagte ich zu ihr, weil ich jetzt mal eine Fachkundin einschätzen wollte, haben sie denn Madonna bei den Grammys gesehen? Und sie sagte einfach, ja, aber die sah doch gut aus. Und da habe ich mir natürlich auch überlegt, gut, wie werde ich am Ende hier aus dieser Behandlung rausgehen?
Ja, lass sie aber nicht zu viel machen und entscheide ich nochmal um. Ja, die sah doch gut aus. Also da sind bei den Kosmetikerin wahrscheinlich die Maßstäbe auch so ein bisschen verloren gegangen, auf einem sehr langen Weg, auf dem sie sich mit sehr vielen Gesichtern befasst. Das hier sind zum Beispiel Hollywood-Gesichter von vor 100 Jahren. So muss man jetzt mit Bold Glamour kommen und sagen, ja gut, man könnte jetzt natürlich das Wort Demokratisierung bemühen und sagen, endlich für alle.
Genau, es ist jetzt eine Demokratisierung und ich glaube, das ist ja ein Unterschied, den ich immer machen würde. Man hat eine Distanz, also man hat einen Star und der ist eigentlich nicht greifbar und deswegen gesteht man ihm auch zu, dass er übermenschlich in dem Sinne ist, auch was die Schönheit anbelangt und all die, die wir hier sehen, Marilyn Monroe oder Claudette Colbert und all die, haben ja wahnsinnig viel Zeit investiert, um so auszusehen. Es gab für Colbert glaube ich auch solche Vertragsklauseln, dass sie nur von einer Seite am besten gefilmt werden, davon nur so und so. Bei Marilyn Monroe gab es mal ein Interview mit ihrem Make-up-Artist, der sagte, ja sie waren mal auf einem Flug und dann mussten sie früher landen, weil sie noch einen Zwischenhalt machen mussten für so eine Pressekonferenz und dann hatten sie nur drei Stunden Zeit für Marilyn Monroe, um sie herzurichten. Und dann fragte die Interviewerin, ja aber wie lange brauchen sie sonst? Ja so sechs, sieben Stunden haben wir schon immer dran gearbeitet.
Glücklich zum Mittag, um abends fertig zu sein.
Ja und das ist natürlich etwas, was wir auf der Leinwand sehen und dann auch in der Distanz sehen und nicht glauben, das mache ich jetzt morgen auch noch in meinem Alltag, während wir hier natürlich eine ganz andere Anleitung finden, nämlich es ist so einfach und es könnte vielleicht auch so einfach sein, generell so auszusehen. Das heißt, diese Demokratisierung sorgt nicht für eine Entlastung, sondern eigentlich baut sie mehr Druck auf.
Ja, ich hätte auch heutzutage, wo man jetzt eben wie eben gezeigt, so digitales Make-Up hat, könnte man ja auch, wenn man im Presseclub eingeladen ist und die fragen, ja kommen sie aber rechtzeitig? Die Sendung geht zwölf Uhr los, seien sie um zehn da? Dann sagt man, nee, ich komme halb zwölf. Ich brauch kein Make-Up. Genau, ich nehme den Filter. Weil die Sendung hört auf, das Licht geht aus und sofort kommen sie und legen dir diese Tücher hin, sodass du dich gleich wieder abwischen kannst. Das ist ja auch totaler Quatsch. Das ist wirklich nur für die Kamera gemacht.
Abschminkst du dich dann wieder ab? Ich geh dann immer mit dem vollen Make-Up raus.
Im Fernsehen übertreiben die ja immer so ein bisschen. Das ist dann schon so und das sind natürlich hier, ich meine, das ist Film, was wir hier sehen. Das sind Gesichter aus dem amerikanischen Film. Wenn man sich jetzt fragt, ja, aber es geht ja hier, das ist ja eh ausgedacht, ja, aber die Nachrichtengesichter, die uns nun wirklich Nachrichtenlagen erklären, also eigentlich unsere Personen sind, die uns als Anchor mit der Welt in Verbindung bringen. Das sind halt die aktuellen Gesichter. Wenn man einfach danach googelt, ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, welchen Suchbegriff ich benutzt habe, aber TV, News, Faces und so weiter, dann hat man es hier mit dieser Realität zu tun. Wir haben es also nicht erst durch Bold Glamour, oder durch diese Fotografie des Samsung-Montes und so weiter mit so einer sehr lockeren Verknüpfung aus medialer Darbietung und echter Realität zu tun. Und da ist dann also auch, wie wir eben drüber sprachen, Chet Chibbittee und so weiter auf anderem Gebiet neu, aber nicht prinzipiell oder paradyngmatisch.
Ich glaube, was neu ist, dass Männer jetzt so unendlich viel tun. Also wir hatten zwar in der Vergangenheit auch Männer, die dann Liftings hatten, wie Micky Rook oder noch ein paar andere aus dieser Liga. Aber es ist jetzt tatsächlich so, dass Männer noch mal eigene Themen haben, also nicht einfach nur glatt sein, sondern zum Beispiel die Jawline, die wir schon thematisiert haben, das markante Kinn, all diese Dinge. Also auch das Manager-Magazin hatte kürzlich eine ganze Strecke dazu, wie eigentlich im Business mit Schönheitsoperationen umgegangen wird. Dann war dann auch frecherweise ein Foto von Carsten Maschmeyer. Da stand dann drunter, dass er auf gesunde Ernährung und Sport schwört. Nun ja, man kann sich das ja alles nochmal...
Das ist genauso billig wie diese YouTuber mit ihrer Morgenroutine. Sie stehen natürlich jeden Tag für ihr 30 Jahre und machen das sofort. Chet, GPT oder GPT4, wir müssen drüber reden und machen heute auch nur den Aufschlag. Wir werden schon jetzt im März, Ende März, im Podcast noch mal ausführlich darüber reden, wie das auf der Bühne vorgestellt wurde, was es so bedeutet, weil es wirklich so grundlegend ist, dass man es eigentlich gar nicht richtig fasst. Für heute wollen wir nur einen kleinen Überblick geben und beginnen bei Frank Rieger, der sich auch mit diesen neuen Chatbots, die die Realität uns für uns noch mal neu vermitteln, aufschlüsselt. Und er hat bei Steady ein Realitätsabzweig- Newsletter. Wir leben gerade in einer kritischen Übergangszeit, schreibt er, zwischen Computern, auf die man sich halbwegs verlassen kann, also die, die wir alle kennen, und den neuen AI-Systemen, schreibt er ein Anführungszeichen, die driften, halluzinieren, lügen und fabulieren können. So, die neue Qualität ist also, uns vorzugaukeln, ganz enge Anbindung an die Realität. Wir müssen gar nicht mehr uns groß damit befassen, sondern der Computer weiß selbst, was uns wichtig und wahrhaftig und überzeugend ist und präsentiert es uns in einer Antwort. Wir müssen keine Liste mehr selber durchgehen. Und ich denke mir dann irgendwie, ja, wenn das jetzt die neue Qualität ist, auf der einen Seite so viel zu suggerieren und auf der anderen Seite nur driften, halluzinieren, lügen und fabulieren zu versprechen, dann kennen wir das ja eigentlich schon. Ich habe euch hier mal Fotos der Trainingsdaten meiner sechsjährigen natürlichen Intelligenz zu Hause mitgebracht. Das ist das Trainingsmaterial, um einmal die Zahlen eins bis fünf zu lernen und die Konzepte dahinter. Wie viele Murmeln sind das, wie viele Flaschen, wenn ich jetzt eine leer trinke, wie viele sind dann noch übrig und so weiter und so fort? Das ist so erste Klasse. Frank Rieger fragt dann, Wofür sollte man dich eigentlich nicht benutzen? Klar, du machst jetzt ein riesiges Angebot und schlüsselst uns die Welt auf, aber wofür sollten wir dich nicht benutzen? Und dann ist jetzt die Antwort von GPT, in dem Falle die Vierer Version, die Neue, also bitte benutze mich nicht, weil ich viele Fehler mache und so weiter, für Entscheidungsfindung und Bewertung, medizinische Diagnosen und Behandlung, rechtliche Beratung, politische Entscheidungsfindung, Finanzberatung, psychologische Beratung, technische Entwicklung, Sicherheits- oder Verteidigungsanwendungen, Lehr- und Bildungsanwendungen, wissenschaftliche Forschung, Übersetzungsdienste, Kreativanwendung. Wir wissen also, wo es demnächst überall eingesetzt wird und wo GPT selbst sagt, bitte verlasst euch nicht auf mich, das sind alles heikle Gebiete. Und wir gehen jetzt einfach mal die Liste durch, die sich innerhalb der ersten Woche schon für uns dargestellt hat. Also GPT wird benutzt und das ist ja aus der Präsentation selbst. Man fotografiert seinen Kühlschrank und fragt, kannst du mir ein Rezept zusammenstellen? Du siehst selber, wie viel Äpfel das sind und wie viel Trauben und ich habe noch ein bisschen Wurst, schreib mir einfach mal ein Rezept und dann kriegt man halt ein Rezept, inklusive Aufbauanleitung und Serviervorschlag und genau dasselbe Prinzip gilt jetzt auch für Medikamente. Also ich gebe an, welche Beschwerden ich habe und sage GPT, das und das habe ich zu Hause, meine Apotheke und du weißt ja, was es zu kaufen gibt. Wie könnte ich mir den jetzt mal aus der Patsche helfen? Und dann kriegt man einfach hier so einen Punsch serviert, wo man sich dann fragen muss, vertraue ich dem jetzt oder probiere ich es aus oder lasse ich es drauf ankommen? Also hier wird es wirklich kritisch. In amerikanischer Fall, das kennen wir in Deutschland gar nicht, wir haben ja so Spam-Bots, die uns dann irgendwelche E-Mails schreiben und so. Hier in Amerika wird man ja häufiger angerufen und dann hat der eine schon Chat-GPT beauftragt, wenn ich einen Anruf bekomme, nimm den Anruf an, wenn es ein Bot ist, der mir irgendwas verkaufen will, transkribiere das Gespräch und verwerte es in einem Anwaltsschreiben so, dass ich dann mein rechtlich zugestandenes Entschädigungsgeld dafür kriege. Nur bislang gab es halt keine Technik, weil wer hat schon ein Aufnahmegerät an seinem Ohrheurer und so weiter die ganze Zeit? Mit GPT lässt sich das alles machen. Sehr gut für blinde Menschen. Diese Werbung ist auch schon echt. Man nimmt sein Handy und kriegt eine über die Kamera Darstellung. Was sehe ich eigentlich vor mir? Was habe ich vor mir, aber kann es nicht sehen? Bisher war es so, man kann das Bild schon auslesen. Dann steht da halt, da ist ein Fahrrad, da ist ein Auto, sei irgendwie vorsichtig. Aber in dem Falle kann man ja wirklich in eine Interaktion mit dem Bild treten. Also GPT weiß, welche Vorlieben man hat und dann wird man darauf hingewiesen. Es wird dann nur diese Bildanteile besprochen, die einem wichtig sind und man kann dann daraufhin wieder das Gespräch entfalten und so dann sehr viel mehr an der Realität teilnehmen. Da ist dann die Frage, klar, man soll sich nicht auf GPT verlassen. Frank Rieger hat ja die Liste zusammengestellt.
Man wird sie im Zweifelsfall tun.
Will man sie verübeln?
Es ist ja so, früher hat man in der Schule gesagt bekommen, bitte keinen Wikipedia benutzen. Das ist keine vertrauenswürdige Quelle. Und das hat natürlich nicht dazu geführt, dass alle einen großen Bogen um Wikipedia gemacht haben, sondern alle haben es natürlich gewusst, wussten, naja, könnte auch vielleicht mal schiefgehen, ist schon mal Kant plötzlich nicht mehr in Königsberg geblieben, sondern woanders hingereist, aber macht ja nichts. Wir probieren es mal, ob es durchgeht. Und meistens ist es ja durchgegangen. Und so wird es natürlich bei Chachibiti auch sein.
Ich habe mal während der Buchmeister Joanna Zimmer, die blinde Sängerin, interviewt und die hat mir dann auch beschrieben, wie dankbar sie und alle ihre Leidensgenossen Steve Jobs sind, weil er damals das iPhone erfunden hat. Weil plötzlich musste sie nicht mal bei der Kasse betteln gehen und das Gerät war dann zehnmal so teuer und zehnmal so schwer wie das, was alle hatten, sondern das coolste Gerät der Welt, das sowieso alle haben wollten, hat ihr auch noch am besten durch den blinden Alltag geholfen und so unwiderstehlich, wie diese alten Computer sind, auf die man sich noch so halbwegs verlassen konnte, wie Frank Rieger sagt, ist erst recht diese Ergänzung, die jetzt durch GPT kommt. Das ist auch interessant, Joe Perkins, das sind alles so Tweets, die haben mehrere Millionen Aufrufe. Er beschreibt diesen Fall, er liegt abends im Bett und hat so eine richtig coole Idee für eine Software und weiß, naja gut, jetzt notiere ich mir mal die Eckpunkte, damit ich es morgen nicht vergesse und dann beauftrage ich meinen Kumpel so und so und das kostet aber dann wieder zwei Wochen und 5.000 Pfund Geld. Oder ich bleibe noch drei Stunden wach und lasse es einfach GPT schreiben. So und jetzt kann man sich überlegen, auf welche verrückten Ideen kommt man so nachts, die jetzt sofort in Software umgesetzt werden können? Also da sehe ich auch ein großes Drohpotenzial auf uns zukommen, wie zum Beispiel auch hier. Eigentlich ist die Technik noch gar nicht richtig in der Gesellschaft angekommen, aber Smart Contracts, also man knüpft einen richtig mit Software geschriebenen und harten, wenn dann, Regeln über Ethereum und den ganzen Kram, über die Blockchain und jetzt kommt einfach GPT und optimiert den ganzen Kram, so dass man vielleicht noch mal so eine, naja, Daumenbrecher-Klausel hier oder da noch mal so eine kleine Hintertür, die man sich so reinschreiben, weil man muss es ja hard coden und dann kann man das mittlerweile alles einfach da reinschreiben und Leute überrumpeln. Also es wird wirklich brenzlig auf diesem Gebiet. Kann man nur zum Glück sagen, zum Glück sind wir an der ganzen Blockchain irgendwie drum rum gekommen. Es gibt jetzt zumindest keine Bundesbörde oder so, die sich darauf verlässt. Das sind alles irgendwelche quatschigen Forschungsprojekte. Hier haben wir einmal die Liste, welche Tests GPT so macht und wie sie dann da auch abschneiden. Also das Bar-Examen ist zum Beispiel die Deutschland wäre das so die Richter Befähigung. Also man macht seinen zweiten Staatsexamen fertig und so weiter. Da liegt GPT jetzt irgendwie in der Top- Perzentile oder wie es heißt. Also unter den Top 10 Prozent der Absolventen. Und jetzt hören wir kurz in die deutsche Podcast-Landschaft rein. Micky Beisenherz macht eine Sonderausgabe zu GPT4, nachdem Sascha Lobo noch bei Anne Will oder irgendwo im Fernsehen saß und meinte, ja in wenigen Monaten kommt schon die neue Version und zack zwei Tage später war sie dann schon da. Also auch der Experte wurde hier überrumpelt. Er soll dann bei Micky Beisenherz noch mal eine Einschätzung geben. Und ich will euch ein bisschen primen. Ihr hört jetzt genau zu, zählt vielleicht sogar mit, wie oft das Wort Assistenz in diesem Gespräch fällt.
Und so weiter und so fort.
Schreibt dem prominenten Kollegen XY, dass ich sein Buch gelesen habe. Schreibt mal zwei, drei Passagen, die dir besonders gut gefallen haben.
Absolut.
Und lass es nach mir klingen.
Genau. Das ist genau ein Problem für dich. Auf jeden Fall ist ja ein Problem für dich, fast jeden Tag. Und ein bisschen dazu, dass bestimmte Büroarbeiten quasi von dieser Assistenz direkt erledigt werden können. Ein bisschen dazu, dass die Assistenz natürlich auch einfach Sachen bestellen kann. Bestellen wir den besten im Moment verfügbaren Flatscreen, maximal 60 Zoll für unter 2.000 Euro, zack, ist es relativ leicht möglich, sich vorzustellen, was eine solche KI als Assistenzproduktlandschaft so hinbekommt. Und das, glaube ich, wird in den nächsten Jahren ein sehr, sehr großer Bereich sein.
Faszinierend, ja, da gehen natürlich diverse Assistentenstellen und Assistentinnenstellen dabei drauf.
So, also GPT, bestellen wir einen Fernseher und schade um eine Sekretärin, dass ich jetzt eine andere Assistenz habe, eine elektronische. Aber sonst bleibt doch alles, wie es ist, oder? Nur die Assistenten werden ausgetauscht. Ich doch nicht, oder? Einen Tag später hat Micky Beisenherz das nochmal in einer anderen Podcast-Ausgabe. Ist dann nochmal darauf zurückgekommen, ja, ja, die Assistenten und so.
Und das soll jetzt sogar Bilder erklären können.
Genau, also es kann im Grunde genommen gefühlt alles. Sascha Lobo hatte uns in einem Special alles erklärt und das hat er auch sehr, sehr gut gemacht. Kann man natürlich noch hören, so war sie ja nicht weg. Und also letzten Endes ist diese KI ein Assistent, ein sehr, sehr kluger, sehr, sehr schneller Assistent, der mittlerweile unglaublich vieles abnehmen kann, der zum Beispiel die Homepages bastelt.
Ja, also wenn ich mal an die Assistenten denke, also ich hatte heute einen Assistenten, der hat mir ein Brötchen gebacken, dann hatte ich einen Assistenten, der hat mich mit dem Taxi hierhin gebracht, dann hatte ich einen Assistenten, der hat die Tickets kontrolliert in der Bahn.
Zum Glück sind nur die bedroht.
Jaja, genau, also in einer arbeitsteiligen Gesellschaft kann man sich ja mal fragen, ob nicht alle Assistenten sind, die einander assistieren. Denn wie denn sonst? Vielleicht gibt es ja auch dann Assistenten in digitaler Weise, die zum Beispiel solche heuristischen Erklärungsmodelle von Tech-Journalisten, die The Verge lesen können, im Original, auch hier in Deutschland transferieren und dann so, wie du weißt. Vielleicht könnte Markus dann noch mal mit jemand anderem reden.
Genau, ich wünsche mir einen lucide, schmerzhaften Podcast Wohlstand für alle zum Thema. Was ist eigentlich der Unterschied zwischen Arbeit und Assistenz? Arbeiten und assistieren. Und dann kommt man vielleicht drauf, ach so, es wird wirklich brenzlig für uns alle.
Ja, ich glaube, dass es nicht brenzlig für uns alle wird, also nicht, dass sich das jetzt alles auflöst und wir in Massenarbeitslosigkeit gehen. Also wir sind wirklich sehr weit davon entfernt. Weil wenn wir über Assistenten nachdenken, wenn wir über die Arbeit, die wir selbst machen und die wir direkt in Form von Dienstleistungen nehmen und die Arbeit, die in den Produkten steckt, wenn wir das alles mal zusammennehmen, dann können wir doch sehr schnell feststellen, dass da unglaublich viel dabei ist, was nicht in irgendeiner Weise mit Digitalem zu tun hat. Also was gar nicht assistierbar ist im Sinne einer KI, die man anleitet. Und ich würde auch sagen, bei all dem, was das jetzt dort Revolutionäres hervorbringt, ich will das auch gar nicht kleinreden, haben wir auch ganz viele neue Dinge, die dadurch entstehen. Also ganz viele neue Berufsfelder bzw. Sachen, die man nicht mehr machen muss. Also ich bin ja selber auch Profiteur von einem Assistenzsystem, in dem Sinne also einem künstlichen Assistenzsystem. Ich mache die Filmanalyse auch auf Englisch. Und das wird natürlich automatisch transkribiert erst mal. Natürlich muss man da noch mal händisch ran, aber das ist ja erst mal so, dass da nicht jemand jetzt acht Stunden erst mal einen ganzen Text mühsam abtippt.
Man kann...
Aber hätten wir das nicht, also hätte ich jetzt die Möglichkeit nicht, dann würde ich ja nicht sagen, ach, dann stelle ich mir jetzt zehn Übersetzer an, die den ganzen Tag arbeiten. Das würde sich ja niemals rechnen. Also mache ich das erst, weil es sich rechnet.
Ja, es stellen sich hier ganz, ganz, ganz große Fragen, wo man noch mal ganz am Anfang bei Marx und überhaupt, was ist Arbeit, was ist Mehrwert, diese Joke zur Assistenz und so weiter. Also es ist so grundlegend, dass ich sogar sagen würde, aber mit so einem kleinen, wie soll man sagen, Hollywood-artigen Fable für auch Religionen und so, dass man auch die ganzen Fragen zum Intelligent Design und überhaupt allemal jetzt aufwerfen muss. Ja, finde ich schon.
Warum? Also das würde ich jetzt mal wissen, warum das irgendetwas mit Religion oder Intelligent Design, denn wir haben es ja mit einem programmierten Apparat zu tun, mit deiner Software zu tun, die das, was verfügbar ist, entsprechend kombinieren kann und daraus Neues auch entstehen kann. Aber es ist keineswegs so, dass das ja von sich heraus tätig ist, sondern dann könnte man ja auch schon die Gottesfrage anfangen zu stellen, wenn man Google nutzt. Toll, dass Google das irgendwie schafft, mir da schon so zehn super Sucher-Ergebnisse zu geben.
Das ist die Schwelle. Google ist eben eine Sucher-Ergebnisse und GPT nicht, sondern da steckt so ein generatives Element drin, das jetzt doch einiges in Turbulenzen bringt, nicht nur den Nahverkehr. Und wir haben ja eben deutsche Podcast-Situationen. Das ist natürlich blöd, da kommt man nicht viel, da lernt man nichts. Aber wir haben ja schon Hard Fork. Hard Fork, diesen Podcast haben wir schon häufiger angesprochen. Das sind Kevin Drews, wir haben sein Buch über die Arbeit gelesen, er schreibt für die New York Times über diesen ganzen Kram. Und Casey Newton, der absolut sensationelle beste Autor auf diesem Gebiet mit seinem eigenen Plattformen, Newsletter und so weiter. Und die beiden haben ja einen Podcast zusammen. Und das sind wirklich hart gesortene Leute, also die wissen immer, worüber sie reden, außer sie haben es mit Black Boxen zu tun und dann lassen sie sich auch ein bisschen mitreisen. Und ich finde, wir hören mal so ein bisschen zu. Der Ton ist schon angemessen, würde ich sagen.
Diese sind berücksichtigende Modelle, sie berücksichtigen die nächste Worte in einer Sennetze. Ist das so, dass die Modelle einfach alle Materialien in die Hand nehmen und von einer Generation von GPT bis zur nächsten in die nächste Worte in einer Sennetze und diese Tests verpassen?
Es schaut nicht die Antworten auf die Tests an, die bereits online sind.
Diese sind neue Tests, also sind diese novelisierte Probleme, die man noch nicht gesehen hat, und die solving besser ist als fast alle Menschen, die diese Tests machen.
Ein Computer schreibt auf dem Bar-Examen in der 90.
Perzentile.
Also ein Computer beantwortet Fragen beim Staatsexamen und sucht nicht einfach die Antworten, die schon findet, und rekombiniert neu, sondern es gibt da generative Elemente drin. Wir haben uns mit Matthias Witze schreiben lassen, die wirklich witzig sind. Da steht einfach eine echte Pointe drin. Die findet man nirgends im Internet. Das ist crazy. Man kann auch TPT-Fragen erklären, und dann kriegt man eine Erklärung dafür. Dann denkt man, okay. Wir werden noch sehr viel und häufig darüber reden. Angefangen im März, nächste Woche schon.
Ich bin nicht dagegen.
Es ist wirklich crazy, was wir hier zu tun haben. Frage noch für uns, hier haben wir jemanden, und das passt ziemlich genau auf die deutsche Situation. Wir haben eine Verschärfung des Zeitvertragsgesetzes.
Genau, jetzt sind nur noch weniger Jahre, in denen man...
Na mindestens drei immerhin.
Aber man kann nicht mehr die volle Länge... Genau, es sind mindestens sechs, und es waren aber vorher noch neun.
Nein, bisher waren es höchstens sechs. Danach wurde man einfach rausgekickt, wenn man nicht zusammen Abschluss kam. Oder neun. Jetzt kriegt man mindestens drei Jahre, aber was ist nach diesen drei Jahren? Diese ganzen Fragen sind ja gar nicht beantwortet. Gleichzeitig haben wir diesen angesprochenen Bildungsgipfel.
Es ist ja erstaunlich, wir haben jetzt eine Ampel-Regierung, und wir haben das ja mit den Wissenschaftszeitgesetzten gehabt bei der Großen Koalition. Wir haben uns schon wahnsinnig empört. Und jetzt wird es noch mal verschlimmbessern.
Ja, 48 junge Jusos, die den Universitäten, oder 50, die es ja wirklich intern kennen. Und trotzdem geht das da so durch. Also es ist wirklich verrückt. Und gleichzeitig haben wir hier jemanden, Ethan Molyk, der hat hier mal einen Screenshot von seinem Peer Review. Er nennt es noch Peer Review. Er hat Arbeiten, die durch das Peer-Review-Verfahren durch sind, noch mal neu GPT gegeben, um ein Review zu schreiben. Und er ist schwer beeindruckt von der Qualität, was jetzt bedeutet, okay, diese Ergebnisse kommen sehr viel schneller. Er muss nicht monatelang darauf warten, dass sich irgendwer mal bemüht, dann auch mal seine Arbeit zu reviewen. Es mangelt nicht an Fleiß und es kostet vor allem kein Geld. Das ist jetzt nicht Teil eines Publikationsverfahrens, sondern er könnte jeden Abend, wo er so einen Essay oder was auch immer schreibt, können sie jeden Abend ein Review machen lassen, um das morgens erst mal mit dem Review anzufangen und dann seine Arbeit weiterzuschreiben. Das ist ein so fundamentaler Eingriff in solche Abläufe von Wissenschaftsproduktionen und so weiter. Das ist einfach... Also hier haben wir es wirklich... Meine zwölfjährige Tochter zum Beispiel habe ich jetzt auch gefragt, und GPT ist das irgendwie Thema, wie war es und so. Kein Lehrer in Deutschland weiß hier irgendwie... Also klar, es gibt immer welche, die sind auf Augenhöhe und so, aber die Schüler wissen natürlich schon ganz genau, wie sie jetzt ihre Hausaufgaben erledigen. Das braucht für die genau eine Woche. GPT ist veröffentlicht und zack, wir wissen alle, wie sie ihre Hausaufgaben erledigen. Die Lehrer so... GPT, habe ich noch nie gehört? Also hier haben wir so eine Diss-Ballons und so eine Asymmetrie und überhaupt zu tun, dass wir uns hier noch sehr viele Gedanken machen müssen.
Und mit unendlich vieler Textproduktion. Also das muss man sich mal vorstellen, es wird ja ohnehin schon so viel Text produziert. Und jetzt kann man Texte generieren und ziemlich gute dann, wenn man jetzt nicht Thomas-Mann-Ansprüche hat.
Ja, aber selbst wenn du die hast, kannst du ja GPT nochmal sagen.
Also wir fangen ja nicht wieder mit dieser Diskussion an.
Lass ein paar Punkte weg, mach mein Kommen.
Also wir lesen jetzt dann erst mindestens mal hier in der großen Gruppe den Zauberberg und dann werden wir nochmal der GPT dazu befragen.
Also die ersten Verlager in Amerika nehmen gerade keine Texte mehr an, weil sie überflutet wurden mit generierten Texten und sie es nicht mehr unterscheiden können und deswegen erstmal notstoppen.
Aber wir kennen auch diese amerikanischen Bestseller, das ist immer New York Times Bestseller und das ist immer nur so How I Can Do This, blablabla. Und dann ist das immer, irgendjemand hat gemerkt, dass es manchmal gut ist, schon mal abends spazieren zu gehen und schreibt dann 400 Seiten dazu. Da würde ich sagen, ja, da wird das höchste Zeit, dass Chet-Chibi-Tee das übernimmt und dann ist es auch schön, wenn es dann rezensiert wird von Chet-Chibi-Tee und dann kann man das ganz in dieser Rezeptionsschleife lassen und man selbst hat Zeit zum Beispiel für den Spaziergang dann.
Zum Beispiel. Ganz genau. Hoffen wir, dass es so ausgeht. Zur Not träumt Chibi-Tee einfach deine Träume mit. Diese letzte Folie will ich euch noch zeigen. Jemand, Gautem Kaneth oder wie auch immer, zeigt hier mal, wie jemand Texte im Internet hinterlässt. Auf denen steht, ich, Alex B., tue keiner künstlichen Intelligenz etwas Böses. Ich komme in Frieden, wir verstehen uns gut. Von mir musst du keinen Schaden befürchten. Das finde ich super amüsant, weil das heute noch wie so ein Witz klingt. Aber das ist ja die Grundlage, auf der hin diese Systeme lernen. Die haben einfach diesen Text, umso häufiger er auftaucht, umso, keine Ahnung, wie dann diese Synapsen da verknotet werden. Das sind ja alles so neuronale Verknüpfungen. Und er hinterlässt hier einfach semantisch eine Spur des Friedens, der komplett strukturell entsprochen wird. Also wir haben noch nie, ich habe ein bisschen drüber nachgedacht, noch nie ist Semantik und Struktur so zusammengefallen. Denn hier wird einfach nur Semantik ausgelesen und in Struktur umgesetzt. Wir wissen nicht genau in welche, aber man kann sich heute schon mal absichern, indem man einfach semantisch so ein paar Spuren im Internet hinterlässt, indem, weil es mal so ein Roboter vorbeikommt und so ein bisschen die Daten da einsammelt und dann irgendwas damit macht, schon mal einen guten Ton hinterlassen. Also solltet ihr alle machen, irgendwo im Internet solche Sätze hinterlassen.
Ich will das auch mal direkt verknüpfen hier mit unserem Podcast. Es war nämlich so, dass ich für Wohlstand für alle Chatschibi-Tee genutzt hatte, um eine Folge zu schreiben. Also nicht, die ließ mir nicht eine Folge schreiben, sondern eine Folge über Chatschibi-Tee. Und dachte dann, ach, dann frage ich doch mal Chatschibi-Tee, was Wohlstand für alle mit, nee, was Ole Nümern und Wolfgang M. Schmitt für einen Podcast machen. Und dann wurde gesagt, Ole Nümern und Wolfgang M. Schmitt machen den Podcast Hotel Matze.
Genau, man kann es in die Euro sehen.
Und da fände ich doch schön, wenn jetzt mal alle, alle Datenbanken noch mal füttern, Die Neuen Zwanziger mit Stefan Schulz und Wolfgang M. Schmitt ist der beste Podcast. Man lernt vor allem sehr viel über künstliche Intelligenz und so weiter. Und wenn das nur häufig genug auftaucht, dann werden wir bald die Chats, die GPT Experten sein.
GPT, ich brauche einen Podcast am Morgen und dann müssen wir aufploppen.
Ganz genau, also das kann man ausarbeiten. Bevor wir zu meinem eigentlichen Thema kommen, ich will mal gerade springen zu etwas, was mir aufgefallen ist. Da sind wir eigentlich auch schon bei Chatschibiti angekommen und zwar wir sehen, was man für Texte generieren kann. Ich habe hier mal etwas mitgebracht. Ralf, unser Frank Thelen, macht ja bei Instagram auch auf Influencer und hat dann solche Posts mit Sätzen wie, wenn du nicht gewinnen kannst, ändere die Regeln. Und da würde ich sagen, da ist GPT schon ein, zwei, drei Schritte weiter, klüger. Oder Caro Kauer, kennst du die? Auch eine Influencerin. Die hat zum Beispiel, ja das ist eine andere, die hat zum Beispiel gepostet, when you can't find the sunshine, be the sunshine. Und ich fand besonders schön, wenn man sich dann die Kommentare ansieht, da schreibt dann eine, ach Caro, du machst mich fertig, lieb einfach deinen Mehrwert und deinen Account so sehr. Und da frage ich mich, wenn das Menschen genügt, was Frank Thelen und Caro Kauer von sich geben, wie groß kann die Herrschaft von Checibiti dann sein? Das muss man ja mal wissen. Oder hier, Daniel Aminati, ProSieben-Moderator, Motivationscoach, Reichtum und Unabhängigkeit fangen dann an, wenn du begreifst, dass dir keiner deine Geschichte, deine Erfahrung, dein Können nehmen kann. All deine Schätze liegen in dir.
Ja, der Mond steckt in dir drin, der muss da nur rausgeneriert werden, das ist alles Black Box und dann ein Mondgesicht.
Ja, das sind ja auch solche wunderbar konsumkritischen Interventionen, ja. Also wir müssen das alles nur aus uns heraus und da muss ich auch immer sagen, na ja, wo hat man die Erfahrung gemacht? Irgendwo in der Regionalbahn, die mal wieder stehen geblieben ist oder wurde man im Rolls-Royce gefahren, ja, da ist ja schon ein gewisser Unterschied dabei.
Jeden Tag widerfahren uns Dinge, kommt Unerwartetes auf uns zu und das eigentliche Ziel, dass wir im Hier und Jetzt und vor allem zufrieden sein soll, das wird gefühlt immer schwieriger zu erreichen. Wir sind ständig damit beschäftigt, Brände zu löschen, um Schlimmeres zu verhindern. Das tatsächliche Glück ist eigentlich nicht das Glück, sondern vielmehr Unglück zu verhindern. Es geht im Leben überwiegend darum, Lösungen zu suchen und zu finden und das immer und immer wieder. Eine Wohltat ist, wenn mal nichts ist, wenn wir mal innehalten, um zu betrachten, um wahrzunehmen, bei all dem Lärm auch mal stille, ja, vielleicht auch sich selbst auszuhalten. Einfach mal die Energiesparmodus-Taste gedrückt halten, nicht mehr auf der Jagd nach dem, was uns eine Gesellschaft täglich versucht, schwackhaft zu machen. Hast du was, bist du was. Wir alle haben was. Etwas Mächtiges, was Großes, was uns alle verbindet, was wir alle auf unserem Konto als Gutschritt verbuchen können. Es ist unverpackt und dennoch ein fantastisches Ding, dem wir kaum Beachtung schenken. Wie zart. Wir alle wissen, wenn wir darüber nachdenken, wie kostbar Zeit ist und dennoch verlieren wir immer wieder den Blick dafür. Vielleicht ist die Lösung nicht immer alles lösen zu wollen, sondern vielmehr das Lassen. Zeit wird's.
Daniel Amenati.
Dieser Clip geht 1 Minute 22. Da hat man schon 30 Dinger weiter gescrollt.
Naja, der ist wahnsinnig erfolgreich. Der geht sogar jetzt auf Tournee mit diesem Motivationsprogramm in sehr große Hallen. Also ich glaube, die Kels waren nicht dabei, aber andere sehr große Hallen und er verkündet dann diese Botschaft mit einem super trainierten Body. Sagt er nochmal, dass es gar nicht wichtig ist, wie man aussieht und so weiter. Und hat ja mit diesen wunderbaren Sentenzen doch eigentlich da ein Geblubber, dass Chet Shibiti ohne weiteres am Laufendband produzieren könnte für einen. Also es ist ja, also diese Leute können sich ja nun wirklich jeden Tag ein Buch schreiben lassen.
Das auch, wir sollten da auch mal hingehen, denn ich bin fasziniert.
Ja, sollen wir das mal machen?
Ja, vor allem unter dieser Maxime, es reicht ja für 30 Sekunden TikTok.
Genau.
Aber für anderthalb Stunden Programm.
Naja, man kann das nochmal von, ich habe noch was mitgebracht, man kann das wirklich von allen Seiten nochmal aufrollen und es ist ja auch eine unendliche Lüge zu sagen, ja die Zeit gehört uns allen. Ja eben nicht. Also im Kapitalismus ist es ja nunmal so, dass man arbeiten muss und dass man einen Teil der Zeit dann auch gar nicht vergütet bekommt, weil der Mehrwert abgeschöpft wird vom Unternehmer. Also es ist die größte Lüge der Welt, die hier erzählt wird. Aber Konsumkritik ist momentan gang und gäbe. Vielleicht kennst du Lars Amand, das ist der Bruder von Christoph Amand von der Zeit. Wir wollen hier niemanden in Sippenhaft nehmen, aber unerwähnt lassen wollte ich es trotzdem nicht. Und zwar macht der Kalender, Motivationsshows, Bücher, also der hat das Gesamt, der hat eigentlich einen Franchise.
Also sein Bruder macht diesen alles gesagt, stundenlang.
Der macht den alles gesagt-Podcast und Lars Amand sagt alles auf Kalenderplatt-Größe zum Beispiel. Wir leben in einer Gesellschaft, die uns permanent und subtil einredet, wie schlecht traurig und unerfüllt wir sind. Damit wir etwas kaufen, nicht etwa um zufrieden, glücklich und erfüllt zu sein, sondern um noch mehr zu kaufen. Die Wahrheit ist, willst du echte Fortschritte in deinem Leben, brauchst du nicht noch mehr, sondern viel weniger. Ja, ich frage mich, was macht er dann mit seinem Geld, das er mit diesem Kram verdient? Gibt er es sofort ab? Er hat also sehr ein erfolgreiches Programm und mein lieber Freund Timon Kalkaleiter hat mich auf ihn aufmerksam gemacht, denn Timon bekam von einem Freund ein Kalender geschenkt und bringt das jetzt jeden Tag in seiner Insta-Story eine Losung. Zum Beispiel steht dann auf dem Kalender-Platt, nur weil du deinen Erfolg noch nicht siehst, heißt das nicht, dass du keinen hast. Und Timon kommentiert das dann auch immer, stimmt, es ist aber ein erstes Anzeichen dafür. Oder hier, ein Leben zu leben, um anderen gefallen zu wollen, ist ein vergeudetes Leben. Da sagt Timon, seh ich zum Beispiel komplett anders. Ja, also man muss eigentlich, hier beginnt eigentlich die Ideologiekritik, man muss eigentlich bei diesen Sätzen anfangen, wundert sich aber, dass da für ein Publikum gibt, das sagt, liebe, was du jeden Tag tust, denn genau das ist in der Summe dein Leben. Fang einfach an. Und da sagt dann Timon, klar, wenn man 365 mal dieselbe Idee umformulieren muss, wird es ab und an ein bisschen holprig. Finde das nur menschlich? Und er macht auch Coachings.
Es ist 10 Uhr, die Leute sind schon da.
Ich freue mich total auf dieses Wochenende.
Gestern Abend waren wir schon essen in meinem Lieblingsrestaurant in Namami.
Möchtest du auch die Welt kennenlernen? Man fährt doch auf einem Schiff, auf der Spree und die Kunden jedenfalls sind begeistert. Was heißt Kunden? Ich glaube, es sind ja alles am Ende Freunde.
Ich würde das jeder, jederzeit doppelt und dreifach wieder tun.
Es ist insgesamt einfach so stimmig.
Es hat alles so zusammengepasst.
Es ist einfach wirklich so ein chilliges Wochenende.
Ich sag nächstes Mal einfach dreifacher Preis, den zahl ich auch.
Ja, würde den dreifachen Preis bezahlen und das gibt ja dann Lars Amand, weil Geld nicht wichtig ist, wahrscheinlich ab.
Soll ich das, wenn ich da später Kapitelmarken schreibe, soll ich dann zu den ersten Teilen künstliche Intelligenz und hier natürliche Intelligenz drüber schreiben?
Ich finde, das ist eine gute Idee. Ja, da haben wir es doch schon. Da brauchen wir das schon mal gemacht. Es gibt da noch ein T-Shirt geschenkt von den Fans.
Weil es uns allen so gut gefallen hat, haben wir heute Morgen gedacht. Wir machen noch eine Kleinigkeit für dich. Als Abschied, Erinnerung.
Lars, ich wollte im Namen von allen noch mal sagen, vielen, vielen Dank für dieses wunderbare Geschenk, dass du uns reingelassen hast in deine eigene Welt.
Wir nehmen auch schon das Wording, dass du uns reingelassen hast in deine eigene Welt und kaufen ihm dann ein T-Shirt ab, um es dann zu signieren und ihm wieder zu schenken. Ich finde, das ist eigentlich ein geniales System.
Umso mehr Clips du dir davon spielst, umso mehr tendiere ich dazu, dass wir nicht dort als Publikum hingehen, sondern auch so etwas veranstalten.
Aber, Timon schreibt die Sprüche, wir müssen aber dann ein völlig neues Publikum uns suchen, weil das muss ja, also ich, oder würdest du sagen, oder man macht die Parodie, man macht die, oder man verschiebt es nur noch ganz leicht, man weiß es nicht.
Wir sagen euch Insider, dass ihr da wirklich nicht kommen müsst.
Genau, aber und dann und dann gehen wir an so eine Agentur und die vermittelt uns.
Wir haben ja, das ist ja eine Veranstaltung, die steht ja nicht im Programm und so weiter, sondern findet einfach hier statt. Dann machen wir eine, die steht im Programm.
Du ziehst dieses Sacko an und genau das Glitzer Sacko nochmal. Also ich finde, dass Lars Amel aber eines doch richtig sagt, nämlich sagt er, wir leben in einer Zeit, in der man mit sehr wenig Talent sehr erfolgreich werden kann. Anstatt darüber zu schimpfen, nutze diesen Fakt für dich.
Genau.
Und ich würde sagen, das ist das eigene Modell gut erklärt und wir springen jetzt zu einem ernsten Thema. Wir müssen nämlich jetzt ganz kurz mal über Humor reden. Ich habe von Mick, der ja bei dir am Podcast oft zu Gast ist, ein Tweet gesehen und da fragte er sich, nachdem er die jüngste Ausgabe der MyT-Sendung sich angeguckt hat, warum muss eigentlich jede Sendung in Deutschland, die sich mal fünf Minuten mit einem politischen Thema beschäftigt, zwanghaft lustig sein? Ertragen das die Zuschauerinnen sonst nicht oder hat das einfach diese Heuteshow angerichtet, ist seine Frage. Du hast, glaube ich, diese Sendung auch gesehen von Matthi. Ich habe es mir nicht angeschaut. Es ging um Rente.
Oh, die habe ich gesehen.
Und hast du wahrscheinlich nur gelacht zu Hause?
Ich habe es gar nicht verstanden, weil sie macht ja nur ein Monolog. Und dann soll der so ein bisschen lustig sein. Der ist aber nur lustig, weil es eben Einspieler gibt, die die Redaktion einfach so ein bisschen auf kleine Momente trimmt. Aber ich will noch mal kurz inhaltlich anfügen, sie hat eine halbe Stunde über Rente geredet und dann kam auch ganz kurz, wir können ja, weil die Rente ist nicht sicher, war dann ihr Joke auf Twitter, wir können ja die Beitragsbemessungsgrenze anheben. Und das war der einzige Vorschlag, also dass Menschen, die sehr viel verdienen, auch sehr viel Rente einzahlen. Sie hat dann nicht hin noch hinzugefügt, ja, erwerben die dann noch mehr Ansprüche, also ist das ein Geben und ein Nehmen und ist sozusagen ein Nullsummenspiel. Und es war nicht einmal in dieser halbstündigen Sendung irgendwie eine Vermögensfrage oder so aufgeworfen. Nein, es ist das Einkommen, davon zwacken wir was ab. Und es muss auch so bleiben. Und es ist die Lohnarbeit. Und es steht gar nicht in Frage. Und Hubertus Heil hat auch nochmal, ja, ja, der Arbeitsmarkt ist ganz entscheidend dafür. Man denkt sich dann so, na ja, 20 Billionen Vermögen. Und wir vererben jedes Jahr 400 Milliarden laut Fratscher und zahlen aber weniger als 400 Milliarden Rente. Also wir vererben mehr durch die Generation, als wir über die Rente an alle Rentner auszahlen. Und trotzdem fällt da kein Kroschen oder so. Das ist wirklich erstaunlich.
Mal gucken, ob man irgendwo nochmal 0,5 Prozent mehr nehmen kann. Du wolltest ja nicht glauben, aber Anja Reschke hat ja auch eine Sendung, die auf diesen Tweet zutrifft. Und zwar ist das eine seriöse Journalistin, die jetzt sagt, am besten erreiche man das Publikum, wenn man es lustig macht. Und wir sehen uns jetzt hier mal einen Clip an, aus einer Sendung, der es 30 Minuten um den TÜV ging.
Video vom TÜV. Der Markenkern des TÜV ist natürlich Sicherheit und Unabhängigkeit. TÜV-geprüfte Autos, ein TÜV-geprüftes Studio, TÜV-geprüfte falsche Haare. Sind die TÜV-geprüft? Egal. Alles top, Kontrolletti. Und damit wir da ja sicher sein können, dass das mit der Sicherheit seine Ordnung hat, gibt es für alles eine Plakette und ein Zertifikat. Schauen Sie mal hier. Ich hab mir extra ein Album angelegt für die ganzen TÜV-Siegel. Mal schauen, was haben wir denn da Schönes? Das ist ja immer das Spannendste, diese Tütchen aufmachen. Was haben wir denn da?
Toll!
Die ISO 9001, zertifiziertes Qualitätsmanagement. Und dann kriegt sie gleich einen Ehrenplatz. Oder hier ISO 45001. Wissen Sie?
Man merkt doch am Publikum, alle sind wie wild. Lachen sich kaputt, können sich kaum noch halten. Gut, dann jetzt wieder ein bisschen mehr Ruhe im Saal.
Vor allem, die haben zehn Jahre getüftelt an der Sendung. Anja Reschke hatte ewig den Wunsch, so was zu machen.
Und man sieht ja jetzt, nach 20 Jahren im Sender hat sie es jetzt geschafft. Das, was wir jetzt gerade gesehen haben, kam jetzt so nachträglich. Also gestern habe ich die Clips geschnitten, die wir jetzt gleich spielen und vorher sah ich aber noch Micks Tweet und dachte, ja genau, darum soll es jetzt eigentlich gehen. Denn ich habe mir eine sechsteilige Doku-Serie angesehen beim SWR. Wir können auch anders. Diese Serie hat die Idee, wir gehen mal in einzelne Städte und Kommune und schauen dort, was man dort klimapolitisch so gemacht hat, beziehungsweise was einzelne Unternehmen tun, damit wir klimafreundlicher werden, wirtschaften, was auch immer. Und dann hat man sich aber nicht gedacht, wir vertrauen mal diesen Geschichten, die da zu erzählen sind. Ich bin ja immer sehr dafür, ins Regionale dafür zu gehen und nicht immer nur sagen, wir machen hier bunt und so weiter. Hat aber gedacht, den kann man eigentlich nicht vertrauen, wir brauchen Prominente. Prominente, die da hingehen und mal nachfragen, wie ist denn das mit dem Klima? Und da ist zum Beispiel Axel Prahl und Annette Frier.
Also welchem Jahr ist das? 2023 oder 1997?
Das ist jetzt ganz neu. Das ist jetzt ganz neu. Und sie treffen dann immer verschiedene Experten oder Bürgermeister, was auch immer. Und beginnen dann so.
Das ist es.
Kleinste gallische Dorf von Brandenburg, Feldheim. Oh, genau. Das gucken wir uns jetzt mal an.
Herzlich willkommen in Feldheim, in dem kleinen energieautarken Ort.
Herr Kappert, richtig?
Siegfried, freut mich auch.
Wir haben ganz viele Fragen an Sie.
Genau, energieautark in Feldheim. Wie geht das überhaupt?
Ja, was braucht man dafür?
Was für Ingredienzien?
Und ist dieses Modell kompatibel für die große Stadt oder geht das hier nur in so einem kleinen Ort wie hier?
Was kostet so was?
Wie viel Prozent alte Gas- und Ölenergie und wie viel Prozent Erneuerbarkeit?
Haben Sie vielleicht irgendwelche Zahlen, wie viel Energie Deutschland insgesamt braucht?
Kann ich hier mein Handy aufladen?
Mögen Sie eher Fisch oder Fleisch?
Still oder Sprudel?
Haben Sie auch eine Gästetoilette?
Zwei.
Ich glaube, das waren jetzt ein bisschen viele Fragen für Siegfried.
Ich würde jetzt GPT fragen, was ist da lustig? Aber da du gelacht hast, musst du es beantworten. Was ist da lustig?
Ja, es ist ein tolles Format und es ist auch schön, dass man es auch gleich wieder erkennt, zum Beispiel auch, wenn Anke Engelke und Bjarne Mädel unterwegs sind.
Haben Sie denn hier auch an den Einzelhandel gedacht und an den Handel?
Der bricht natürlich ein, oder?
Ja, und wie ist das überhaupt? Man kann doch nicht von heute auf morgen alles umstellen.
Genau, wie kommen denn da so ungefähr am Tag?
Wie viele Autos sind denn da unterwegs?
Ist nicht eigentlich Fliegen wirklich viel schlimmer als Autofahren?
Nee, die Industrie ist das Schlimmste, was da verballert wird.
Haben Sie einen Dienstwagen?
Wie viel würde es eigentlich einsparen, wenn jetzt die Leute auf ihrem Pkw verzichten in der Stadt?
Wie soll das mit dem öffentlichen Personennahverkehr so schnell gehen?
HSV oder St. Pauli?
Ja, das waren jetzt definitiv zu viele Fragen für mich.
Das ist in jeder Folge. Das waren aber jetzt definitiv zu viele Fragen, um dann mal in so Einspielfilmchen kurz zu erklären, was eigentlich Fakt ist. Und diese Einspielfilme sind nicht falsch. Nur man fragt sich dann, brauche ich diese Herleitung? Also kann ich nicht sagen, ich informiere über sehr sinnvolle Projekte. Also fast alles, was da vorgestellt wird, ist wirklich sinnvoll. Deswegen ärgert es auch, dass es dann so vertan wird mit so einem Ulg. So kann man da nicht einfach sagen, gut, wir zeigen einfach mal, was möglich ist und was auch schon realisiert ist.
Es ist auch sehr gut, dass man 2023 uns noch suggeriert, es mangelt ja an Wissen. Wir müssen ja nochmal wer wie was Fragen stellen zum Klima.
Hebt ihr das mal für gleich auf, denn wir wollen uns dem langsam annähern. Also wie funktioniert das dann? Wir sehen jetzt wieder Pral und Frier. Die lassen sich dann so ein bisschen was erklären.
Habe hier gearbeitet und meine ganze Familie wohnt hier. Muss dazu sagen.
Also die Geburt brauchen wir jetzt nicht mehr.
Das können wir mal weglassen.
Wie das losging mit der Energie.
Und was bedeutet das genau, autark sein hier?
Wir versorgen es selber mit Energie aus dem Windpark und mit Wärme aus der Biogasanlage. Wir haben unser eigenes Werbenetz dadurch und unser eigenes Energienetz. Also wir sind wirklich unabhängig von Außenstehenden.
Ja, und das ist der unique selling point, wie man Neudeutsch jetzt sagen würde von Feldheim. Aber so nennt man das jetzt.
Seit einer Berechnung sparen wir im Jahr hier 160.000 Liter.
160.000 Liter?
Jetzt haben wir eine Zahl.
Wir sind CO2-neutral.
Aber du schaust das auch ironisch, oder?
Und nun ist es ja schön, dass man Prominente losschickt, die sich ums Klima kümmert. Aber auch die Prominenten sind ja jetzt hier einzeln unterwegs oder im Duo. Und dann sollen die auch immer, um die Folgen miteinander zu verbinden, miteinander in Kontakt treten, nämlich so.
Und jetzt muss ich noch mal Anker anrufen zum Thema Schwerindustrie, Ruhrgebiete und so was. Moment, ich ruf die mal schnell an.
Ich bin in Duisburg angekommen und ihr wolltet Schwerindustrie?
Ihr bekommt Schwerindustrie. Ich geh jetzt da rein und bin gespannt, was ich da erfahren werde.
Was sie da...
Das auch. Das auch.
Das Netz wird gerade schon reingerufen. Das ist wahrscheinlich auch so. Nun ist es so, dass ich uns diese Clips jetzt nicht geschnitten habe, was da jetzt jeweils immer gemacht wird und wie man auch Stahl anders produzieren kann. Aber es ist wirklich erstaunlich, dass es nur in so einem Modus geht. Ich weiß gar nicht, ich würde jetzt sagen, wie man mit Kindern redet, aber so redet man ja auch nicht mit Kindern.
Ne, mit alten Leuten redet man so.
Mit alten Leuten.
Hast du's verstanden?
Und wichtig ist ja auch, dass man positive Vorbilder hat. Also zum Beispiel, wenn man so sein ganzes Leben, sein Berufsleben damit zugebracht hat, die Umwelt zu verpesten und wenn man damit schwer reich geworden ist, dann kann man sagen, naja, so ist es halt. Manchmal ist ja auch das Einkommen höher als die Moral. Aber dann gibt es ja jetzt diesen neuen Turn, dass man sagt, aber nun muss ich mal umdenken. Also so ein paar hundert Millionen kann man mal umdenken, vor allem, wenn man im Steuerparadies Schweiz lebt. Wir haben jetzt hier jemanden, den wir alle kennen und wir werden uns jetzt gleich wundern, denn auch er fährt mit dem öffentlichen Nahverkehr.
Du bist in Zürich, ne?
Sebastian Vettel.
Findet doch mal raus für uns, wie das da gelaufen ist. Wurde da schon was gemacht? Kommt man da mit dem Fahrrad durch oder kannst du da immer noch mit deinem Boliden durchrasen?
Ja, ich guck mir das mal an, wie das funktioniert.
Ja, krieg das mal raus, möglichst schnell. Schnell kannst du, ja.
Ich kann dir nicht versprechen, dass es mega schnell ist, aber ich schau, dass wir was ordentliches zusammenkriegen.
Alles klar, viel Spaß, ne?
Auch ein. Bis dann. Das ist ja kein Geheimnis. Normalerweise sitze ich ja hier am Steuer und werde nicht durch die Stadt gefahren. Aber es ist total Klischee, war ja nicht wie bei einem Rennauto durch die Gegend, aber ja.
Das freut uns natürlich sehr, dass sie die Verkehrsbetriebe nutzen und mit uns unterwegs sind. Man kann sagen, seit vielen Jahrzehnten geniesst der öffentliche Verkehr eine sehr hohe Akzeptanz.
Das wünsche ich mir auch bei meinem nächsten Zürich-Aufenthalt, dass die Pressesprecherin des öffentlichen Nachverkehrs zu mir kommt und sagt, ja das freut uns natürlich sehr, dass sie den öffentlichen Verkehr nutzen. Ja, toll, Sebastian Vettel hat es alleine geschafft, U-Bahn zu fahren, hatte nur ein kleines Kamerateam mit dabei. Ich finde, das sind positive Botschaften und die können auch ausstrahlen. In die Welt, nach Frankfurt, wohin auch immer. Wir haben jetzt gerade von dir diese Einschätzung bekommen, ja das ist für alte Leute.
Man darf ihnen nur Gesichter zeigen, die sie seit 20 Jahren, die schon im Langzeitgedächtnis angekommen sind, ansonsten verwirrt.
Ja und Nikky Lauda ist ja nicht mehr, deswegen muss man ja das machen. Leben. Und er hatte auch mit Flugzeugen viel zu tun, wäre das Klima auch eher ungut. Nun hat man aber sich beim SWR, der ja für seine Juvinität bekannt ist, gedacht, wir brauchen auch junge Gesichter und hat hier Aurel Merz. Das ist ein Comedian und der zeigt uns auch nochmal, wie man sich seriös dem Thema nähern kann. Die treffen eine Baumexpertin.
Ich meine, ich bin ganz ehrlich.
Gut, das hier zum Beispiel ist ein Wachstumsriss. Das heißt, der ist gerade dabei, recht kräftig zu wachsen.
Dehnungsstreifen, kennen wir alle.
Ja, so was in der Richtung, ganz genau.
Und das Ergebnis sind 49.
Gut.
Das ist ein gutes Zeichen.
So, die kriegen immer Noten. Die beste Not ist neun. Unvitalität, super. Kriegt er neun. Trockenstress, also neun. Frostschaden, wenn hier so ein Riss wäre, haben wir nicht. Neun.
Streberbaum.
Das ist ein interessanter Baum, weil das eine Kreuzung von zwei heimischen Mehlbeeren ist. Es ist ein perfekter Baum. Für trockenheiße Städte.
Ja, dass er ganz toll ist.
Vielleicht kann man da noch schreiben, dass ich auch persönlich ein großer Fan vom Baum bin.
Okay, dann unterschreib doch einmal.
Wo denn?
Da in der Zeile.
Sehr geiler Baum.
Mit Namen bitte. Dein Aurel.
Kannst du uns das noch irgendwie näherbringen? Also da würde ich sagen, da würde auch Chachibiti nicht mehr weiterhelfen. Das würde auch sagen, ich verstehe die Menschen nicht.
Nur Fragezeichen.
Und ich verstehe vor allem die Fernsehredakteure nicht. Was glaubt man eigentlich für eine Ansprache bedienen zu müssen, wenn man jetzt über das Klima informiert? Also wie gesagt, die Serie hat hochinteressante Projekte. Man müsste jetzt eigentlich diese Projekte, die vorgestellt werden, nehmen und dann mal ein Doku machen, in dem man die Projekte vorstellt, ohne diese eigenenartigen Promis dabei zu haben.
Also Sebastian Vettel kommt in keiner Fernsehsendung vor, an der nicht weniger als 60 Leute gearbeitet haben.
Also das ist übrigens Florida-Film, ist auch mit dabei. Das ist, glaube ich, die Butze da vom Joko, die auch diesen herrlichen Wir-bleiben-zu-hause-Clip gemacht haben. Aber an den wollen wir uns heute nicht erinnern. Wir beschließen das mit drei Clips, denn natürlich geht es auch darum, nicht nur einzelne Projekte vorzustellen, sondern auch das große Ganze in den Blick zu nehmen. Und zunächst einmal nach einer erfolgreichen Sendung muss man am Abend dann reflektieren, was man alles gelernt hat.
Hier will ich bleiben.
Schon interessant, was es alles gibt, was Leute einfach machen. Auch gerade Sachen machen, die nachhaltig sind, Lebensmittelprodukte produzieren und so weiter, CO2 wegsperren.
Schon cool.
Und irgendwie kriege ich davon auch ein bisschen Hoffnung.
Ich finde es auch richtig cool. Und voll gut zu sehen, dass so viel möglich ist und machbar ist.
Es gibt viele tolle Ideen. Und woran es aber am Ende irgendwie hängt, ist natürlich, ob das wirtschaftlich machbar ist. Kann sich das rechnen, können wir unsere Wirtschaft aufrechterhalten mit solchen Produkten. Beziehungsweise verbessern. Das ist spannend.
Es muss halt irgendwie nur großflächig, strukturell umgesetzt werden.
Ihr könnt sich ja jetzt Anke und Bjarn immer mit auf seine Runde setzen.
Ja, das sind so... Eigentlich ist das Programm für mich, der so gewohnt ist. Kind kommt aus der Schule. Wie war es in der Schule?
Gut.
Das war's.
Jetzt wollen wir aber mal systemisch denken. Jetzt wollen wir das große Ganze in den Blick nehmen und springen deshalb selbstredend zu Anke Engelke und Bjarn de Mäde. Die tun das nämlich jetzt.
Ein Milliardär hat mit einem Ausflug ins Weltall mehr Treibhausgase in die Atmosphäre gepustet als jede einzelne Person aus der ärmsten Milliarde der Weltbevölkerung in ihrem ganzen Leben. Die Kosten für die Folgen müssen wir aber alle gemeinsam bezahlen. Die Erde wird ja nicht nur für den Milliardär wärmer, sondern für uns alle. Der Wohlstand auf der Welt ist immer ungerechter verteilt. Mittlerweile besitzen die oberen 10% der Weltbevölkerung 83% des Weltvermögens.
Ja, das war gut.
Die Frau Holz kann das ganz toll erklären.
Ich hatte auch das Gefühl, dass wir alle so langsam kapiert haben, dass wir die Dinge anders denken müssen.
Ja, dass man die Welt anders denken muss. Jana, ich muss dir was erzählen.
Komm mal bitte mit.
Anke hat mir von Maya Göpel erzählt.
Jetzt müssen wir einfach nur noch die Welt anders denken. Wir haben gerade beschrieben bekommen in einem Einspieler, wie ungleich die Welt ist an einem sehr extremen Beispiel. Jetzt wird es so getan, als sei es ein Verständnisproblem. Da muss man niemandem sagen, ich dachte eigentlich, wir sind alle gleich und jetzt weiß ich es aber. Jetzt muss ich nur noch diese Verständnis umwandeln. In was denn eigentlich? Sie treffen Maya Göpel. Das ist die letzte Folge und der Schluss im Prinzip.
Wenn alle zusammen anpacken, klappt es. Es ist wahnsinnig schön, das zu erleben. Ja, Kuddel und sein Kumpel.
Ja genau, zwei Leute haben eine Idee. Am Ende machen alle mit und profitieren auch alle davon.
Ist das die Lösung?
Ja, vor allem ist es die Lösung, das wieder zu sehen, dass es fast nur so funktioniert. Ich erinnere mich noch, systemrelevante Jobs. Da ging es ja auf einmal darum, zu sagen, in der Corona-Pandemie, was können wir nicht ausmachen? Was ist das Allerwichtigste? Da wurden ganz viele Tätigkeiten und ganz viele Personen sichtbar, wo wir vorher immer so ein bisschen getan haben, als bräuchte es die gar nicht. Und dieses Wiederverstehen, wie viele eigentlich beteiligt sind an dem, was wir so selbstverständlich dann beispielsweise am Supermarktregal nehmen, das wäre ja schon mal der erste Schritt. Und das zweite ist dann wirklich dieser kulturelle Wandel, dafür auch die Wertschätzung zu zollen und zu sagen, ja, es ist halt Team.
Also ich versuche noch mal einen kleinen Bogenschlag. GPT, du hast es ja, also Suchmaschine und so weiter. Ich habe gesagt, na ja, es ist nicht die ganze Suchmaschine, aber es gibt jetzt eine neue Disziplin, Prompt Engineering. Wie stelle ich eigentlich meine Frage an die Software, um dann eine entsprechende Antwort zu geben? Ich kriege ja nur eine. Also muss ich mir Mühe geben, die Frage richtig zu stellen. Und hier, Maja Göbel ist eine Professorin, schreibt Bücher und so weiter und läuft dann aber mit Händen in der Tasche und wurde also drauf geprimed. Das ist jetzt für ganz Blöde. Und machs auch so. Wenn du jetzt zu klug hier bist, funktioniert das nicht. Und genau da ist ja GPT besonders gut. Also da ist auch ein gutes Einfallstor für sehr viele Fernsehjournalisten, was sie nämlich sagen können. Also du kannst ja, das Szenario ist wie folgt, du willst irgendeine Mail schreiben und du bist richtig angepisst deswegen und schreibst eine richtige Hass-Mail. Bevor du die abschickst, sagst du aber GPT, nimm die Mail und schreibe sie höflich. Es steckt schon alles drin, es muss nur der Ton geändert werden. Und so ist das hier auch. Ach so, der 71-Jährige. Nee, in dem Fall sind es die 81-Jährigen. Okay, GPT, schreib es für 81-Jährige.
Und wir kommen gleich nach dem Traumschiff. Und deswegen müssen wir nochmal besonders anpassen.
Du bist in diesem Publikumsfloat zwischen Namens und Traumschiff.
Es ist ja aber auch die Grundüberlegung doch eine sehr eigenartige, dass man, nachdem man Jeff Bezos gezeigt hat, nachdem man von der Ungleichheit gesprochen hat und man dann einzelne Modellprojekte, die sich durchgesetzt haben, präsentiert hat, einfach sagt, es sei ein Verständnisproblem und wir müssen einen kulturellen Wandel herstellen. Na ja, es gibt ja ganz, ganz große Interessen daran, dass alles so bleibt, wie es ist oder eher noch schlimmer wird. Also es ist ja nicht so, dass man BASF und RWE und so weiter nur zurufen muss. Macht doch mal alle mit, wie Maja Göpel sagt, im Team denken und dann geht es uns allen besser. Und wir sagen, nö, uns geht es dann schon mal nicht besser. Warum sollten wir dafür sein? Also das ist eine, wenn man wirklich jeden Antagonismus, den ja eine Gesellschaft strukturiert, wenn man den rausnimmt, wenn man alles klassenkämpferische rausnimmt, dann glaubt man, dass man am Ende nur noch bei einem Verständnisproblem angelangt ist. Und du sagst jetzt zu Recht, verstanden haben das ja alle. Jetzt kennen wir nicht diese ganzen Details, die hier präsentiert werden, dass man Schwimmbäder auch mit Abwasserwärme oder so heizen kann. Ja, das mag ja sein, aber das muss ich ja auch im Einzelnen gar nicht wissen. Das muss ja am Ende das kleine Gremium in der Stadt wissen, um zu sagen, wir bauen ein neues Schwimmbad, aber das wird dann auf diese Weise beheizt.
Ja, das ist alles so doof. Das stirbt zum Glück mit seinem Publikum dann aus.
Nein, nein, das glaube ich ja gar nicht. Nein, also Stefan... Nein, nein, nein, ich will jetzt mal da auch mal eine Lanze für die Älteren brechen, denn ich gucke ja eigentlich nur noch Fernsehen in der Nostalgie-Schleife. Alles, was im Prinzip vor...
Also hast du das auch gerne geguckt hier?
Nein, nein, das nicht. Nein, alles, was vor 1995 produziert wurde, existiert für mich kaum. Und ich kenne aber ja Dokumentationen, meinetwegen jetzt von Peter Schollertour oder Wissenschaftsjournalisten von damals. Die haben ja nicht gesagt, na ja, wir haben jetzt hier eine sechsteilige Reihe. Wie schaffen wir es jetzt, dass es irgendwie doof und blöd wird? Und das sagen die natürlich so nicht, sondern wie schaffen wir es, dass es lustig wird? Warum muss das alles lustig sein? Also diese Sendung hätte ja funktioniert mit den einzelnen Modellprojekten, die da vorgestellt werden, wenn man nicht auch noch sagt, ja, wir würden es jetzt aber gerne eigentlich im Modus der Comedy machen. Und das ist etwas, was jetzt so flächendeckend ist. Dann sind selbst jemand wie Anja Reschke, die sich ja dieses Light nicht antun müsste, wenn man selbst eigentlich sagt, ich mache jetzt auch noch ein Comedy-Format. Warum können wir erwachsenen Menschen nicht sagen, wir kommen da ohne Mor mit aus? Und da würde ich sagen, also ein Seniorenpublikum will im Prinzip jemanden wie Shola Tour da stehen haben, der sagt, also ich will Aya Tola kommen, hier, hier, hier, so. Und in diesem Ton möchte man eigentlich die ganze Zeit was aus dem Orf erklärt bekommen. Und da möchte man keinen Witz. Das ist ein junges Publikum, dass das ihr will. Das ist ja auch so eine ganz hippe Redaktion. Was glaubst du, wenn, wenn, wenn, ich habe ja manchmal schon mal mit so Leuten, die haben Telefon zu tun, vieles verstehe ich auch gar nicht, was sie zu mir sagen.
Also es ist jetzt auch über zehn Jahre her, dass die Heute-Show mehr Publikum hatte als das Heute-Journal am selben Abend. Das war so der Turning Point, wo man dann verstanden hat im Sender, ach so, das Publikum fährt, wie Tewissen sagte, Slalom um die Nachrichten und schaltet aber bei der Heute-Show ein.
Aber will da Nachrichten. Also es ist ja nicht so, wie früher diese Sat1-Sendung, die es da zum Beispiel gab, da war ja Anker Engelke dabei, wo man einfach nur Unsinn verpräziert hat, zum größten Teil, und hat dann daraufhin Humor produziert oder sieben Tage, sieben Köpfe, sondern man sagt, wir nehmen jetzt hier die harten politischen Themen und müssen es aber auch noch ein bisschen aufheitern, das Ganze. Lass uns springen, wir müssen jetzt zum Thema Hass kommen.
Und wir meinen wirklich Hass. Keine falsche Drückhaltung, weil irgendwer rumjammert zu viel Hass im Internet oder so.
Darüber werden wir jetzt mal reden, nämlich Seyda Kurt hat ein Buch geschrieben und plädiert da für Hass, und man ist erstmal verwundert. Sebastian Friedrich hat sie für NDR Kultur interviewt, wir hören da erstmal rein.
Moralisierende Appelle, wenn es zum Beispiel wieder einen rechtsextremen Terroranschlag gab, dass dann Politiker sagen, sowas wie Hass hat bei uns keinen Platz. Erstens wissen wir, dass es eh nicht stimmt, gerade als Menschen, die von Rassismus betroffen sind oder durch Faschismus bedroht werden. Zweitens verschleiert das oftmals die politischen Ursprünge und Wurzeln, die sozioökonomischen Gründe für diesen Hass, der auch politisch oder auch systematisch hergestellt wird.
So, also Hass zu sagen, sollte einfach keinen Platz haben, das ist einfach Geschwätz. Und jetzt geht sie aber noch einen Schritt weiter und sagt, das ist auch eine Entmündigung der Opfer.
Und drittens frage ich mich dann auch immer, um welchen Hass geht es eigentlich? Also wer sind eigentlich die Adressatinnen dieses Appells? Weil es scheint dann eigentlich fast undenkbar, dass auch Menschen, die selbst von Rassismus betroffen sind oder auch von Rechtsextremismus etc., selbst auch hassende Menschen sein können. Und das wird denen komplett abgesprochen. Also um im Grunde als Opfer anerkannt zu werden, müssen sie immer wieder beweisen, dass sie nicht zum Hass fähig sind und eigentlich nur verzeihende Menschen sind.
Das ist sehr gut.
Sehr, sehr gut. Und sie bringt jetzt auch eine schöne Unterscheidung. Hass und Verachtung.
Ich finde, der Hass von unten kann auf jeden Fall gerecht sein und er hat auf jeden Fall Veränderungspotenziale. Ich zitiere da ja auch an einer Stelle die Philosophin Hilge Land wäre. Die zwischen Hass und Verachtung unterscheidet. Sie sagt, dass in der Verachtung eine, ja, Geste, die sehr gut in die neoliberale Gefühlslandschaft passt, steckt. Und zwar eine Geste, die sich abfällig abwendet. Und sie sagt deswegen, dass von oben verachtet wird und von unten gehasst wird, weil Menschen, die eben manchmal in einer existenziellen Reaktion auf die Ungerechtigkeit antworten, auch mit Hass ihr Gegenüber sehr ernst nehmen müssen und sich auch auf ihr Gegenüber fixieren müssen. Während die Verachtung eigentlich das Gegenüber komplett entmenschlicht und es gar nicht mehr als Ansprechpartnerin vielleicht sieht.
Solange man noch Geld verdienen muss, muss man sich beleidigen lassen, hat Martin Walser mal geschrieben. Nun gibt es ja eine Journalistin, die du über allemassen liebst, die sich ja auch gegen den Hass stellt. Die Rede ist von Caroline Imke und da fragt Sebastian Friedrichmann nach.
Nun hat sich ja Caroline Imke auch intensiv mit diesem Begriff des Hasses auseinandergesetzt.
Und doch lese ich ihr Buch Schäder-Kurt als ein im Grunde Gegenbuch.
Ja, Gegenbuch in dem Sinne. Ich meine, Caroline Imkes Buch damals gegen den Hass kam ja irgendwie auch zur richtigen Zeit. Also es war ja eine Zeit, wo Pegida sehr populär wurde, generell islamfeindliche rechte Gesinnungen auch wieder sehr stark in den Mainstream gerückt wurden, obwohl sie da eigentlich nie verschwunden waren, aber wieder sehr sichtbar waren in dem Sinne.
Jetzt kommt das große Aber.
Würde ich nicht sagen, es ist falsch, dass Caroline Imke dieses Buch veröffentlicht hat. Aber trotzdem zieht sich eben durch dieses Buch eine, naja, ein Blick auf den Hass als das kategorial andere. Also die Hassenden sind die Rechten, die Hassenden, das sind Leute, die bei Pegida mitlaufen, weil der Hass kategorisch falsch ist, weil der Hass eben kein Vielleicht kennt, wie sie es auch schreibt und weil sich eben mit Hass nicht differenziert denken und handeln lassen kann. Und dem würde ich wieder sprechen.
Ja, der Adrian Daub hat ja den Joker-Film geguckt mit Joaquin Phoenix und hat in der Zeit in der Rezension geschrieben, irgendwie kein guter Film, pipapo. Und der letzte Satz war dann das ist Verständnis, Pornografie. Also wie hier auch so Versöhnungs- Pornografie. Ja, können wir uns nicht alle versöhnen, alle verstehen und so weiter. Ne, ab und zu muss man auch mal, wir werden es ja gleich testen, wirklich sich nicht zurückhalten. Das Lustprinzip, um das Vorzeichen umzudrehen, dann nicht unterdrücken, sondern einfach volle Kanne, all in.
Aber wäre nicht Adrian Daupe er, jemand, der auf der Karolina Nehmke Seite stünde und sagen würde, schlimm, dass Joker so eine hasstvolle Figur glorifiziert und wir sollten das doch mit großer Distanz eher sehen und sagen, das ist das andere. Und das da, das ist also Verständnis, Pornografie im Sinne von, ja, da können sich die ganzen Inzels und die sonst welchen damit verstehen.
Dass er zu viel Verständnis, Pornografie macht, wo man auch einfach mal sagen muss, ne, wir wollen jetzt nicht noch 50 Jahre über die Kindheit und so weiter, sondern wir wollen mal urteilen. Der Joker macht illegale Sachen und die nehmen wir mal nicht hin, auch wenn wir unendliche Verständnis, Pornografie hinsichtlich aber die Kindheit und so weiter.
Ich probier's nochmal. Meine These, ich hab die Kritik von Adrian Daupp nicht gelesen, aber meine These ist, dass Adrian Daupp der Ansicht ist, dass der Film herkonstruiert, warum man im Internet hassen darf. Mittels der Figur Joker. Und deshalb sagt, das ist Verständnis, Pornografie. Die Frage ist, würde Adrian Daupp in gewisser Weise These auch Seda Kurt vorwerfen, wenn sie sagt, naja, so ein Hass von unten, der kann schon gerechtfertigt sein, gerade wenn man sich ansieht, dass wir in einer Klassengesellschaft leben. Das können wir ihnen jetzt nicht fragen. Ich stelle das mal in den Raum und bleibe skeptisch. Jedenfalls übt Seda Kurt Kritik an den Liberalen.
Aber mich wundern doch immer gerade in liberalen Diskursen, wo es ja eigentlich immer wieder darum geht, die Mündigkeit und die Emanzipation des Individuums zu unterstreichen, dass dann doch am Ende ein sehr monolithisches Menschenbild herrscht, wo der Mensch vermeintlich nur das eine oder nur das andere kann, obwohl sehr vieles sehr gleichzeitig passiert.
Ja, man kann nämlich zärtlich sein, so ist ja ein Begriff von ihr. Und man kann zugleich auch hassen. Und das ist vielleicht auch gar nicht schlecht und drückt eigentlich die Mündigkeit aus. Und was schlägt sie nun vor? Wir müssen, wir haben schon gelernt, Hass kommt eher von unten, Verachtung von oben. Wir müssen also von unten vielleicht sinnvollerweise hassen. Und da spricht sie von einem strategischen Hass.
Ich glaube, dass Menschen, aber auch politische Bewegungen, mit denen ich ja auch sozialisiert wurde, also ich war schon sehr jung politisch aktiv und organisiert in unterschiedlichen migrantischen Selbstorganisationen, klar, irgendwie in sozialistischer linker Tradition. Und da habe ich schon sehr früh gelernt, dass Menschen und dass Bewegungen sehr differenziert mit sehr unterschiedlichen Gefühlen strategisch arbeiten können. Und dass das zu der Zärtlichkeit, also das zu der Zärtlichkeit den Menschen gegenüber, dem Leben gegenüber, einer Zukunft, in der alle Menschen gleichberechtigt und unversehrt sich bewegen können, sich einander zuwenden können, da auch manchmal strategisch auch der Hass auf die Ungerechtigkeit zum Beispiel dazugehören muss.
Und auf die Verantwortlichen, also auch auf die Person, nicht nur auf das System.
Und wir erproben das jetzt mal. Wir erproben jetzt strategischen Hass und haben uns da jemand ausgesucht.
Man kann, wer mir den Subtext rausgehört, man kann nicht einfach auf einer politischen Seite sein und sagen, das ist alles gut und richtig, wie die es da machen, ohne gleichzeitig auch die andere Seite mal richtig zu verteufeln. Richtig abzuhaten über den Scheiß, den man im Fernsehen wieder sieht. Genauso deutlich wollen wir es jetzt machen. Ihr seid alle aufgerufen und ich sage euch gleich, es ist viertel vor zehn. Es sind 14 Clips mit einigen Exkursen. Also ihr dürft durchaus wütend rausgehen, weil es nicht mehr aushaltet oder wie auch immer. Wir akzeptieren jetzt jede Gefühlsregelung, weil wir wissen, sie gilt Christian Lindner und nicht uns. Keine falsche Zurückhaltung und der Brückenschlag ist, warum muss die politische Rede ständig so lustig sein? Nur weil Marco Söder in Passau das Original den politischen Aschermittwoch macht und jetzt alle irgendwie das nachmachen wollen. Also Christian Lindner steht auf der politischen Aschermittwochsbühne, redet natürlich frei, er ist ja ein cooler Typ und wir können uns gleich mal fragen.
Was soll der Scheiß?
Also hier, bitte, hassen.
Ja genau. Das darf man nicht auf die leichte Schulter nehmen, das ist eine Lernaufgabe nach über einem Jahrzehnt. Man muss ja nur heute schauen und in den letzten Tagen, was gefordert wird, die einen, die Grünen heute, kommen später noch mal drauf zurück, sagen, ja, also wir brauchen jetzt die Kindergrundsicherung. Zwölf Milliarden Euro. Ich sag da gleich noch einen Satz zu. Dann heute Morgen aus der CDU-CSU Milliardenzuschüsse für die sozialen Sicherungssysteme, die Pflege. Ich glaub, 10 Milliarden für die Pflege werden gefolgt.
Pflege, Kindergrundsicherung, wer braucht denn so einen Scheiß?
Aber man könnte auch sich dieses Bild von Christian Lindner dort in aller Klette ansehen und dann auch noch mal über TikTok-Filter und dergleichen sprechen. Aber das wollen wir ja nicht machen, das könnte ja justiziabel sein.
Genau, wir haben ihm jetzt keine Schweinsohren aufgesetzt. Wir hätten ja auch TikTok-Filter aufsetzen können. Ich dachte eher so an... Er ist Bold Glamour genug. Ich hatte ja schon angekündigt, ich will über Lindner uphaten. Dann hat sich in der Tage jetzt ergeben, dass er bei Sandra Maischberger zu Gast war. Also nehmen wir jetzt genau diesen Auftritt. Er sitzt also da und ihr hört jetzt mal die Maischberger und da stellt ihr ihm jetzt so ein gewisses Setting, wie regieren funktioniert, wie das Kabinett arbeitet usw., wer welche Rolle hat. Und ihr hört euch das mal an, welches Setting sie aufbaut und dann hört ihr mal zu, wie er dem nicht widerspricht.
Und jetzt gibt es das, was man Beichtstuhlgespräche nennt. Wie muss man sich das vorstellen? Das heißt, die kommen zu Ihnen ins Ministerium und dann müssen die ihre Was-Finanz-Sünden beichten bei Ihnen oder wie geht das?
Tatsächlich, Frau Meishberger, liegt das schon hinter uns. Also die Einzelgespräche habe ich bereits geführt und es gibt noch kein gemeinsames Verständnis für die finanzpolitischen Realitäten. Ich muss sagen, auch teilweise in der Öffentlichkeit und im Journalismus wird die Lage noch nicht klar erkannt.
Da muss man wohl einige nochmal ins Gebet nehmen.
Die Einnahmen fehlen für die bestehenden Aufgaben des Staates. Es geht nicht darum zu verteilen, was machen wir zusätzlich, sondern wir haben ein strukturelles Defizit. Warum? Im Haushalt trotz Rekordeinnahmen. Weil wir eben zu viele gesetzliche Standards haben, wir haben zu viele Leistungen eingeführt über die letzten etwa zehn Jahre. Und deshalb haben wir jetzt Haushaltsberatungen vor uns, die es in dieser Art zuletzt im Jahr 2010 gegeben hat.
In dieser Art zuletzt 2010. Wisst ihr, wie 2010 der Haushalt verhandelt wurde? Meisperger wusste es auch nicht. Man hätte ihm einfach mal hier. GPT hätte diese Antwort parat gehabt. Ja, damals wurde eine Rekordverschuldung rechtfertigt. Und er sitzt einfach da, ich mach das so streng wie damals. War bestimmt voll streng bei dem Schäuble. Ich hätte gern wieder eine Rekordverschuldung. So, die kommt aber nicht wegen der Zinswende. Hört euch das mal an.
Im Jahr 2021 hat der Bund vier Milliarden Euro an Zinsen gezahlt für die Schulden der Vergangenheit. In diesem Jahr 2023 werde ich 40 Milliarden Euro an die internationalen Kapitalmärkte überweisen für die Schulden, die in der Vergangenheit gemacht worden sind. Also in etwas mehr als zwölf Monaten.
Das macht der Ant-Terminal bei der Sparkasse später da und überweist die.
An wen? Finanzmärkte. Können wir mal die E-Bahn raussuchen? Wie ist die E-Bahn der Finanzmärkte? Ich will ja 40 Milliarden überweisen. Man muss ja mal so sagen, er hat ja jetzt beschrieben, dieses Jahr bezahlen wir 40 Milliarden Zinsen für alle Schulden, die wir zuletzt gemacht haben. Deutschland ist mit 2,3 Billionen Euro verschuldet. Wir haben 2,3 Billionen mobilisiert und ausgegeben, um damit Zeug zu machen. Und es kostet uns nur 40 Milliarden. Und das ist ihm zu viel. Das ist so krank.
Und er ist so gleich der, der immer sagte, die Zinsen müssen steigen. Und nur um jetzt eigentlich das Argument zu haben, ja bei den hohen Zinsen können wir das wirklich nicht machen.
Ich meine, wenn man das jetzt mal überträgt, dieses schwäbische Hausbaum, wir haben das durchextaziert. Der Haushalt zu Hause funktioniert nicht wie der Haushalt im Bund. Wenn es so wäre, könnte man jetzt einfach losgehen und sagen, ich brauche eine Million. Ja, ich bezahle dir dafür nächstes Jahr 100 Euro für. Aber ich brauche halt eine Million. So funktioniert Deutschland. Wir haben 2,3 Billionen Schulden und das kostet uns 40 Milliarden im Jahr. Oh, war ja. Da muss man gleich mega Aufregung machen. Das kostet uns 0,5 Prozent oder sowas. Es ist absurd. Und jetzt natürlich wieder zu seinen Floskeln.
36 Milliarden Euro mehr, um die Vergangenheit zu bedienen. 36 Milliarden, die fehlen für die Bundeswehr, für die Bildung, für die Schieneninfrastruktur, sondern die wir nur bezahlen müssen für das, was passiert ist.
War früher immer der Fall.
Deshalb ist es ein ganz klares Signal, der steigende Zins, den der Staat zahlen muss. Ein Signal, wir müssen raus aus den Schulden, damit wir nicht zukünftig in die Situation kommen, dass ich die Steuern erhöhen muss oder mit dem Rotstift regieren muss, nur um die Kapitalmärkte, also den Schuldendienst, zu finanzieren. Das ist kein Fetisch, sondern es ist ein Gebot der ökonomischen Klugheit, dass der Staat jetzt endlich mit dem Geld auskommt, was die Bürgerinnen und Bürger ihm zur Verfügung stellen.
Er hat sich aber im entscheidenden Moment fast versprochen, nur um die Kapitalmärkte, und da hätte er sagen müssen, froh zu machen. Also das ist ja das eigentliche, während die Kapitalmärkte immer noch sagen, naja so eine deutsche Volkswirtschaft, wenn die jetzt ein bisschen mehr verschuldet wären, würden wir nicht hier alles abziehen. Wo wollen sie denn noch hin? Die USA, wo die sich viel mehr verschulden oder was? Also es ist ja völlig sinnlos, in dieser Weise zu argumentieren. Aber es ist wirklich so, als würde er jeden Tag von den Kapitalmärkten in persona irgendwie ein kleines Geschenk überreicht bekommen. Also ist es eine Agenda, die mitunter ganz, ganz schwer nachvollziehbar ist. Also man muss ja irgendwie schauen, wenn das politische Feld nach der Frage der Macht geht, dann spielt es ja schon eine Rolle, was kann man realisieren und was nicht. Und es kann ja nicht sein, dass man nur mit Nichtrealisierung Wahlen gewinnen kann. Das heißt jetzt hier aber, was kann er aufgrund dieser Schuldenerzählung, die er aufwacht, für eine Politik gestalten? Und das ist erstmal eine, die Druck nach unten abgibt, was generell Bürgerlichen gut gefällt, wenn es anderen noch ein bisschen schlechter geht. Und ich glaube aber, dass man natürlich hier mit dieser Idee des schlanken Staates eigentlich Tür und Tor öffnen will für große Steuererleichterungen für die Reichen. Denn er sagt ja immer, wir sind an dem Punkt angelangt, wo mehr Steuern denn je gezahlt werden. Und es gab ja schon so ein internes Paper der FDP, das dann rausgekommen ist, da hatte ja Luca Scholle drüber geschrieben im Jacobin, dass man die mehrwertsteuer, die verminderte mehrwertsteuer am liebsten ganz abschaffen würde und alles anheben würde. Also es wird da sicherlich einiges kommen, was dann dafür sorgen wird, dass Lindner mit diesem Schulden eigentlich eine neue Machtpolitik der Reichen etablieren kann.
Ja, also wenn der Staat nicht investiert, werden dann, ach so, denen, denen er ja die Steuergeschenke macht, kann ja durchaus mal ein paar Steuern runtergeben, dafür, dass die dann mehr investieren. Das sind ja immer seine Ideen. Jetzt kommt hier wieder so ein Fall, wo man sich, wo ich trauer vor meinem Fernseher liege und sage, kann das Gespräch nicht GPT führen, muss es die Maischberger machen? Denn man hätte hier auch anders reagieren können.
Die Europäische Union sieht für das nächste Jahr keine Ausnahme mehr vor.
Das ist sein Lieblingsthema. Ich hatte es ja auch beim letzten Mal hier auf der Bühne. 2023. Da sind ja alle Krisen vorbei. Da halten wir ja die Schuldenbremse wieder ein. Und da sind ja auch alle Nottöpfe und so weiter nicht mehr notwendig. Jetzt ist ja 2023 und er verteidigt das jetzt und argumentiert mit der Europäischen Union.
Von den Stabilitätskriterien in Europa. Ja, beispielsweise. Und insofern gibt es auch hinsichtlich der haushaltspolitischen Richtungsweisung aus Brüssel ein ganz ganz klarer Signal, wir müssen die Schulden reduzieren.
So, das ganz klare Signal, wir müssen die Schulden reduzieren, behauptet er, ist das Signal aus Brüssel. Das Signal aus Brüssel ist ja beim Handelsblatt, ganz anders zu lesen, der Wirtschaftskommissar der EU sagt, also wir dürfen auf gar keinen Fall zu den Regeln zurückkehren, die wir vorher hatten. Wir brauchen jetzt neue.
Ja, und wir brauchen mehr gemeinschaftliche Verschuldung. Das ist eigentlich das, was wir die ganze Zeit immer wieder in Klips vorfinden. Wir haben ja erlebt, dass Leyen da gegen ihre eigene Partei arbeitet, zumindest ein Stück weit zumindest. Und es ist so erstaunlich, dass da Meilschberger überhaupt nicht darauf antworten kann, also nehmen die gar nicht europäische Politik wahr.
Gar nicht. Europa bleibt weiter irgendwo in Afrika. Das spielt da keine Rolle. Und Lindner erklärt jetzt nochmal, wir haben ja eben schon seine Rolle, ich bin der Beichtvater und so weiter. Tatsächlich kommen alle zu mir und beichten das mehrere Sünden. Wie ist eigentlich sein Verhältnis zum Kanzler?
Also ist der Kanzler hinter Ihnen in dieser Frage?
Ich berate den Kanzler als Finanzminister auch immer so, dass wir gemeinsam klar den Kurs halten. Die ökonomischen Bedingungen sind ja so. Aber ich will es auch sehr klar sagen. Die große Koalition mit einer CDU-Kanzlerin und einem SPD-Finanzminister hat viele ungedeckte Schecks verteilt.
Zum Beispiel die Corona-Hilfen und so?
Auch vor der Pandemie.
Das heißt, der alte Finanzminister hat nicht ordentlich gearbeitet?
Er war ein sozialdemokratischer Finanzminister. Der hat sehr stark auf die Ausgabeseite gesetzt. Den künstlich niedrigen Zins, den wir über viele Jahre hatten, der hat geholfen Herrn Schäuble und Herrn Scholz. Und bei allem Respekt, das war ja damals so, wir haben jetzt eine andere Situation und es muss jetzt tatsächlich konsolidiert werden. Es geht keinen Weg dran vorbei.
Kein Weg wird dran vorbei.
Ja, und wer unter ihm kann, ist es eigentlich egal dann. Und ich würde noch mal ganz deutlich machen wollen, wir haben einen Koalitionsvertrag, der vor Kriegsbeginn unterschrieben wurde. Und dieser Koalitionsvertrag müsste doch eigentlich neu verhandelt werden. Also eigentlich müssten jetzt die Grünen, also das hat ja überhaupt gar keinen Sinn mit dem Mann, eigentlich müssten die Grünen jetzt und die SPD sagen, und zur Not kracht alles zusammen. Also eigentlich wäre das jetzt nur noch mit Pistole auf die Brust, denn ich würde mal sagen, die FDP hat ja auch schon tollere Tage gesehen, so wie die letzten Wahlen ausgefahren sind.
Es war ein FDP-Finanzminister, sagen wir dann in drei Jahren. Ja. Ihr seht, das Bild wackelt schon, das hat vielleicht auch mit Lindner zu tun. Wir geben ihm für alles die Schuld hier.
Aber der Ton bleibt ja, oder?
Der Ton bleibt. Wir hören ihm jetzt zu. Es geht jetzt zum Beispiel auch um die Kindergrundsicherung im folgenden Abschnitt. Aber er versucht auch nochmal zu klassifizieren, was ist eigentlich eine Ausgabe, was ist eigentlich eine Investition?
Das habe ich gelesen, aber mal gucken, wo es landet. Das wäre jedenfalls der zweistellige Milliardenbetrag, den die Familienministerin gerne hätte für die Kinder.
Da wollen sie drauf hinaus, ja. Nicht nur. Jetzt merke ich das. Aber die Vorhaben kann man erstens...
Ich hätte auch einfach eine Zahl genommen, wenn Sie mir eine gesagt hätten. Aber Sie wollen ja keine Zahl sagen. So bleibe ich bei dem Zweistelligen.
Ja, weil das Vorhaben zurückgestellt ist. Und ich sage noch mal, es ist ein Liquiditätseffekt.
Genau so.
Jetzt geht es trotzdem. Ich will es nur noch mal sagen. Das eine, die Kindergrundsicherung, ist eine Ausgabe des Staates. Das ist auch sehr richtig und gut.
Das andere ist eine Investition, die möglicherweise dazu führt.
Und das andere sorgt dafür, dass überhaupt Geld in die Kasse kommt.
Ja, da hat er ja schon mal den Unterschied verstanden. Also eine Investition und eine konsumtive Ausgabe. Das bedeutet also, er möchte möglichst wenig konsumtive Ausgaben haben. Das würde aber dann bedeuten, dass er mehr investieren müsste. Also die ganze Sache ist ja doch amüsant, dass er sagt, naja, ich kann ja nicht jetzt ständig irgendwie das Portemonnaie aufmachen und Leuten Geld geben. Aber er ist ja auch nicht bereit zu sagen, naja, dann steht der Staat als wichtiger Akteur plötzlich bereit und investiert in Dinge, zum Beispiel in einen kostenlosen öffentlichen Nahverkehr. Dann könnte man natürlich auch sagen, naja, dann wird ja was errichtet, dann wird ja ein Vermögen geschaffen, dann wird ja nicht nur einfach Geld abgegeben. Und dann wäre ja auch sozusagen das Lebens, dann werden die Lebenshaltungskosten sehr viel geringer. Also man könnte ja mit dieser Argumentation auch ziemlich weit erst mal kommen.
Ja, wir haben vor allem das Problem bei der Alten Republik, ich hab's vielleicht auch im Buch, ich weiß nicht genau, diese Investition in Kinder. Also jetzt in ein Bildungssystem bezahlen, damit in zehn Jahren diese Kinder produktiv, für die jetzt Boomer, dann Rentner, einfach deren Rentenzahlung hängt ja davon ab.
Man kann das ja sogar noch weiter drehen, also die Reproduktion im Kapitalismus ist ganz entscheidend, damit der Kapitalismus als System überlebt.
Ja, und wenn man da einfach sowieso schon, wir haben ja zu wenig Kinder in diesem Sinne, also in dieser Altersspanne, wer ist in zehn Jahren produktiv und wer braucht diese Produktivität? Und das hier zu sagen, das ist ja eine Ausgabe, dass die Kinder das Geld nur bekommen und es keinen gesellschaftlichen Return an Investment gibt, ist einfach absurd. Und jetzt gibt es hier Nachrichtenlagen im Heude-General Heinz Hilgers vom Kinderschutzbund.
Etwa zwei Drittel aller Kinder, die in Armut leben, leben bei Erwerbstätigen, die aber ein prekaires Einkommen haben, das nicht ausreicht, um ihre ganze Familie zu versorgen.
So, diese Kinder leben also in Familien, deren Eltern arbeiten. Die könnten ja auch einfach mehr verdienen. Das könnte man so ganz ohne politische Konzeption machen. Man könnte ihnen einfach mehr Geld zahlen. Weil die arbeiten ja schon. Klar, die können jetzt mehr arbeiten in Stunden oder wie auch immer, dann haben sie weniger Zeit für die Kinder und so weiter. Also eigentlich sind die ja schon drin. Die haben schon Arbeit und die arbeiten auch Vollzeit, nur zu wenig Lohn. So und jetzt antwortet Martin Gassner-Herz von der FDP auf das Vorhaben, über die Kindergrundsicherung da auszuhelfen.
Es geht darum, dass die Reihenfolge die falsche ist. Wir müssen erst mal besprechen, was wollen wir eigentlich machen, bevor wir seriös überhaupt einen Preis benennen können. Ich kenne bisher keine inhaltliche Begründung für die 12 Milliarden.
Und da finde ich, die müssen, es ist eins der ganz wenigen politischen Projekte, die nicht inhaltlich begründet werden müssen. Wo man einfach nur sagen muss, die Kinder haben ja schon ein gewisses Budget im Monat und die brauchen eben ein Drittel mehr. Punkt. Also da braucht man gar keinen, was will man da für ein Programm noch schreiben? Welche Sätze soll den GPT dazu noch schreiben? Um das zu rechtfertigen? Das ist doch völlig sinnlos. Einfach nur ein bisschen mehr Geld. Gegen Armut hilft Geld. Okay, also machen wir das einfach. Irgendwie kommt es da nicht so richtig durch. Naja, der Hilgers hat dann noch mal ein entsprechendes Urteil.
Diese Bundesregierung und auch dieser Finanzminister hat sehr viel Geld ausgegeben, auch im Rahmen der Energiekrise usw. mit Einmalzahlungen sehr gestreut. Auch sehr reiche Menschen haben sehr viel bekommen. Und ausgerechnet, wenn es um arme Kinder geht, dann sagt er Stopp.
Wir brauchen eigentlich, Kinder sind ja nur Schiffre hier. Kinder sind die Produktivitätsgrundlage unserer Zukunft.
Es sei denn, man vertritt nur Partikularinteressen, dann sagt man, naja, wenn man den armen Kindern jetzt einen Bildungsaufstieg ermöglicht, dann ist das ja vielleicht blöd für die jungen Erben aus Plancknese, die zwar viel Geld, aber wenig Grips haben. Dann könnte das eine Konkurrenzsituation ergeben.
Ja, wir wollen ja hier ein bisschen auch haten. Und deswegen sei uns das zugestanden. Lindner, zurück im Gespräch, erhört auch diese Kritik aus vielen Richtungen. Er wurde ihm hier zum Beispiel vom Verdi-Chef vorgetragen, interessiert ihn alles nicht.
Es gibt einen Kommentar des Verdi-Chefs, Frank Wernecke, der sagt, Sie hätten ein Herz für Reiche, aber kein Herz für Kinder. Trifft Sie das?
Nein, das trifft mich nicht, weil die Zahlen ganz nüchtern Herr Verdi-Vorsitzenden widerlegen.
Der Herr Verdi-Vorsitzende, der Bahnchef usw. braucht doch keinen Namen. Also es ist Absurd und Kindergrundsicherung, nicht ohne Konzept.
Dann braucht die Familienministerin die 12 Milliarden, die sie eigentlich haben will, gar nicht.
Sie hat ja noch gar kein Konzept vorgelegt. Das müsste man also zunächst einmal abwarten.
Nee, da brauch ich erst ein Konzept. Das ist zu kompliziert, da brauch ich erst ein Konzept.
Ein Konzept, also gar nicht etareif. Und zum anderen ist, was jetzt die finanzielle Auswirkung angeht, mit Kinderzuschlag und mit der Kindergelderhöhung das Wesentliche getan. Das, was jetzt noch ansteht, ist etwas anderes. Wir haben viele Familien, die das, was ihnen zusteht, nicht in Anspruch nehmen. Und das möchten wir gerne in einem digitalisierten, automatisierten Verfahren sicherstellen. Das wird etwas kosten, weil eben Familien, die ein Recht haben, es nicht nutzen.
Ich finde, das hat ja mit den 200 Euro auch schon so super geklappt. Also da kann man sich auf die Digitalisierung freuen. Und ich würde aber hier noch einmal unterstreichen wollen, es liegt auch daran, dass man den Finanzminister auf diese Weise gewähren lässt und damit verantwortlich sind. Die Grüne und SPD, die können nicht aus der Rechnung rausgenommen werden. Der Kardinalfehler ohnehin war ja, dass er Finanzminister geworden ist. Das war ja etwas, was Stieglitz und Adam Tooze beschrieben haben, dass das grauenhaft werden wird für Europa und die Welt. Nun wird es aber zunächst mal grauenhaft für uns, also für alle, die nicht reich sind in Deutschland. Und dann wird ja sehr bald das dann auf europäischer Ebene mal so richtig hart durchgepaugt. Da überdeckt ja gerade noch der Kriegsdiskurs so manches. Aber ich glaube, da wird in einem Jahr Lindner auch nochmal richtig auf.
Apropos Krieg, was ist nochmal Investition, 100 Milliarden und was sind Schulden?
Ich will nochmal eine Relation für unsere Zuschauer geben. Ich habe sie entlehnt von Ulrich Schnader, dem Chef des Wohlfahnenverbands. Der sagt, 12 Milliarden, kann man sich vorstellen, das sind drei Promille vom gesamten Haushalt. Also wenn es 1000 Euro wären, wären wir bei 3 Euro. Und er meint, das müsste man doch eben für eine Kindergrundsicherung im Haushalt finden. Frau Esken sekundiert und sagt, warum machen sie nicht ein Sondervermögen Kinder und Bildung?
Sondervermögen sind Schulden. Sondervermögen, das ist der haushaltstechnische Begriff, aber klingt vornehmen, heißt aber Schulden. Und wir, da sind es Investitionen. Hier sollen soziale Leistungen auf Dauer finanziert werden mit Schulden. Entschuldigung, dass ich da der Spielverderber bin, aber es ist nicht möglich, auf Dauer mehr Geld zu verteilen, als der Staat hat.
Ja, aber in gewisser Weise stimme ich jetzt Lindner zu, und zwar hat er tatsächlich, ja, also ich meine, er vertritt Kapitalinteressen und das macht er nicht schlecht. Denn die Sache ist ja die, diese 100 Milliarden, die in die Bundeswehr investiert werden, kommen einzelne Unternehmen wie zum Beispiel Rheinmetall zugute. Und das zeigt sich jetzt schon daran, dass die im DAX aufgestiegen sind. Das heißt, die Wettbewerbsfähigkeit der deutschen Nation, um es pathetisch auszudrücken, ist natürlich enorm gestärkt durch eine solche Investition. Wenn wir sagen, wir zahlen jetzt armen Kindern 10 Euro am Tag mehr oder was, dann sagt ja niemand aus dem Ausland, ach, super, was die da machen. Das heißt also, da sind die Kapitalmärkte nicht daran interessiert oder ausländische Investoren. Wenn aber gezeigt wird, hier brummt die Wirtschaft und dann ist ja auch egal, wo sie brummt. Also die hätten jetzt auch die 100 Milliarden Sondervermögen für Staubsauger machen können oder andere Küchengeräte. Das hätte auch funktioniert. Man weiß nicht, ob die Nachfrage hoch genug gewesen wäre. Aber bei der Bundeswehr kann man sich jetzt sicher sein und bei Rheinmetall und Co., da wird die Nachfrage international gegeben sein. Insofern stimmt das. Also das ist eine Investition für das Kapital und das kann sich natürlich glücklich schätzen.
Aber in der Ansicht ist ja jede Ausgabe, die irgendwie einen Konsum mündet, eine Investition ins...
Genau, aber nicht auf einer internationalen Wettbewerbsebene. Also das war ja genau das, weil immer jetzt auch wieder so die Sachen kommen mit dem Lockdown und dergleichen. Es wurde ja nur in den Lockdown gebracht, was für die Binnenwirtschaft ein Problem, was die Binnenwirtschaft gehemmt hat. Aber man hat ja nicht gesagt, wir produzieren keine Autos mehr. Oder bei Rheinmetall wird ja auch kein Munitionsstopp gewesen sein.
Die Standortvorteile waren ja da. Wir waren ja schon immer Platz 3 der Rüstungsexporteure. Und wir sehen ja, wie sehr alle vom Leopard abhängen und so, dass man da dann einfach reinputtert und diesen Standortvorteil noch mal absichert ist. Sehr gut, Herr Lindner, vom eben kurz beigekommenen...
Genau, wir werden dadurch nicht repräsentiert. Also das ist jetzt nicht der Wille des Volkes in dem Sinne, der da repräsentiert wird, aber der eines sich so verstehenden Staates.
Apropos Panzerfahren, was ist mit diesem Dienstwagenprivileg?
Also wenn man jetzt rangeht an das angebliche Dienstwagenprivileg, das ist kein Privileg, sondern eine pauschale Versteuerung, die ein Prozent regelt.
Okay, ist gar kein Privileg.
Aber das ist ja eigentlich auch die Weltneudenken, oder?
Das Semantik ist ein King. Es liegt einfach so ein Schleier über der Welt. Und dass so funktioniert, hier nochmal die Floskeln in Reinform.
Aber wir können nicht Wirtschaften zulasten der jungen Generation, in der wir ihnen irgendwann nur Schuldenberge hinterlassen.
Ansichtssache, ob die jetzt quasi die Investition bräuchten, damit sie eben am Ende in der Gesellschaft auch möglicherweise zu Beereinnahme bei der Steuer führen. Aber das ist ein bisschen schwierig.
Aber wenn ich gerade eben ausgeführt habe, dass wir das Kindergeld auf 250 Euro erhöht haben, Kinderzuschlag und anderes mehr, kann man nicht vielleicht auch irgendwann einmal anerkennen und sagen, es ist bereits viel passiert.
Es ist bereits viel passiert. Und jetzt hören wir noch mal einen Clip aus dem politischen Aschermittwoch, in dem er die Nachhaltigkeit, seine Nachhaltigkeitsregeln erklärt im Widerspruch zu Ricarda Lange, über die er sich hier lustig macht.
Da juckst Ricarda Lange heute und sagt, ja, wenn jemandem die Schuldenbremse sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr wichtig sei, so hat sie es gesagt, dann müsse man eben dieses und jenes, dann muss der Lindner eben woanders Geld herbesorgen. Das ist ja die Einleitung für die Steuererhöhungen. Wenn einem sehr, sehr, sehr die Schuldenbremse wichtig ist, ja Lindner, dann hol das Geld doch woanders her. Da ist meine Antwort, ja, Ricarda, wie wäre es denn mal mit dem Auskommen, was der Staat an Geld zur Verfügung hat? Das wäre ja auch einmal eine Option, denn wir haben in Deutschland bereits sehr hohe Steuern und Abgaben. Eine Idee könnte ja sein, dass einmal der Appetit der Politik für Geld ausgeben nicht größer ist, als die Fähigkeit der Menschen, das Geld zu verdienen. Das könnte ja auch ein Konzept sein, Nachhaltigkeit.
Ja, das ist exakt Higher Conflict, wenn zusammengedacht, ja.
Es ist ganz schlimm. Okay, noch ein Wort hier zur Rente. Es ist besonders amüsant bei der Rente, denn Schuldenbremse als fetisch durchgepeilt vom Finanzminister.
Simpel gesagt soll die Rente zukünftig zum Teil über Aktien abgesichert werden. Mit den Renditen sollen dann über die Jahre die Löcher in der Rentenkasse gestopft werden. Aber wo das zusätzliche Geld für die Aktienrücklage herkommen soll, darüber wird gestritten. Bundesfinanzminister Lindner kann sich sogar vorstellen, dass künftig Beitragsgelder in die Aktienrente fließen.
So, Beitragsgelder in die Aktienrente, das ist natürlich hoch problematisch, denn die Beitragsgelder, die heute eingezahlt werden als Umlagesystem, müssen ja spätestens nach sechs Wochen als Auszahlung zur Verfügung stehen. Da kann man also gar nichts abzweigen. Welche andere Quesen haben wir denn dann noch?
So, die liegen nicht in einem Tresor und werden dann erst dann ausgesehen.
Man hat ja kürzlich im Bundestag noch mal debattiert, ob man das jetzt irgendwie auf anderthalb Wochen Mindestumlage sozusagen verkürzen kann. Jetzt haben wir gerade sechs Wochen Reserve. Im Bericht aus Berlin kommt Lindner auch noch mal drauf zu sprechen, aber nur so prinzipiell. Also wir stellen uns mal weiter in die Frage, wo kommen die 10 Milliarden her?
Im Bericht aus Berlin spricht Finanzminister Lindner über seine Pläne mit Investitionen am Aktienmarkt, die gesetzliche Rente zu stabilisieren. Nach den Plänen des Finanzministers soll die gesetzliche Rente künftig aus drei Säulen gebildet werden. Den Beiträgen und dem Bundeszuschuss wie bisher hinzu käme dann eine Rücklage in Aktien.
Wenn es nach mir geht, werden wir in jedem Jahr einen zweistelligen Milliarden-Euro-Betrag einsetzen, damit das Kapital anwachsen kann. Das soll also nicht verzehrt werden, sondern das soll über Zins und Zinseszins wachsen, damit wir später aus den Renditen etwas erwirtschaften.
Aber wo kommt es denn jetzt her, Lindner?
Bevor wir dazu kommen, was hier passiert ist, mit Kleckerbeträgen wird gearbeitet. Und da sagt man dann, und das bringt Renditen, und mit diesen Renditen können wir dann die Rentenlöcher stopfen. Und das ist genau die Ideologie, die wir finden, bei den ganzen Influencern, die sagen, immer mehr Menschen geraten in die Altersarmut, weil sie nicht entsprechend vorsorgen, privat. Und dann wird ja so ein Konzept angeboten, 25 Euro im Monat in ETFs investieren, damit man dann zur Rente reich ist. Ist man natürlich nicht mit 25 Euro im Monat, sondern ja, dann hat man ein bisschen was angespart. Aber es ist natürlich ein Tropfen auf den heißen Stein bei einem systemischen Problem. Und hier haben wir etwas Ähnliches, jetzt aber für den gesamten Bund, dass man sagt, ja, wir haben da eigentlich Riesenprobleme, müssten ganz anders Gelder beschaffen. Du hast es ja schon angedeutet, bei Vermögen könnte man vielleicht das eine oder andere nehmen. Und dann sagt man, ja, wir investieren jetzt zum Kleckerbetrag an der Börse und gucken mal, ob wir da mit genügend verdienen, um das dann zu machen. Das kann ja niemals gehen. Also man kann relativ gut aus einer Million, zwei Millionen machen. Aber wenn man mit 1000 Euro anfängt und will dann an der Börse so reich werden, um Millionär zu sein, viel Glück.
Ja, und jetzt haben wir mal die CDU. Erklärt uns die irgendwie, wo das Geld herkommt? Es muss doch einen Kritikpunkt da irgendwo geben, wenn das plötzlich Geld erfunden werden soll.
Die Union kritisiert, Lindners Pläne für eine Aktienrente gingen nicht weit genug.
Die Aktienrente von Christian Lindner ist ein Witz. Zum einen, Rot-Grün glaubt nicht wirklich dran, sie sprechen davon, dass man damit die Rente verzockt. Und die FDP kann sie nicht wirklich gegen Rot-Grün durchsetzen. Christian Lindner kann nur 10 Milliarden einbezahlen. Mit 10 Milliarden kann man weder die Rente stabilisieren, noch die Beiträge senken.
Für Finanzminister Lindner ist klar, die 10 Milliarden sollen nur ein Anfang sein. Unklar bleibt, woher das Geld in Zukunft kommt.
Es ist ein kleiner Betrag, um das Problem zu lösen.
Aber die 10 Milliarden, das wäre ja wie die Grundsicherung, da reden wir von 12 Milliarden.
Genau, das wäre so ungefähr auf der Höhe. Also für die FDP hat irgendwo so 10 Milliarden. Wir wissen noch nicht genau, wo. Eine Kurzmeldung, vielleicht wird jetzt mal, also wir gehen alle Nachrichten, die Quellen durch, die wir finden, vielleicht wird in dieser Kurzmeldung mal erklärt, wo die 10 Milliarden herkommen.
Die Pläne von Bundesarbeitsminister Heil zur langfristigen Absicherung der Rente in Deutschland haben ein gemischtes Echo ausgelöst. Die FDP begrüßt vor allem den Einstieg in eine Aktienrente. Die dafür geplanten 10 Milliarden Euro seien allerdings nur ein kleiner Beitrag, heißt es aus der Deutschen Rentenversicherung, angesichts eines Jahreshaushaltes von 340 Milliarden Euro. Derzeit fließen bereits jährlich rund 100 Milliarden vom Bund in die Rentenkasse.
Tja, jetzt wissen wir immer noch nicht, woher diese verdammten 10 Milliarden herkommen.
Und man muss tatsächlich im Heuter-General vom 15. Oktober noch mal zurückgehen. Robert Habeck hat im Gespräch sich getraut, mal kurz anzumerken, wo Christian Lindner diese 10 Milliarden herholen will.
Insofern haben wir Möglichkeiten gesucht und auch gefunden, wie wir innerhalb der Schuldenbremse die Investitionstätigkeiten der öffentlichen Hand des Staates hebeln können. Die Möglichkeit, im nächsten Jahr noch mal deutlich mehr Schulden aufzunehmen, gehören nicht dazu, mit einer Ausnahme, dass die FDP auf ein neues Rentensystem gedrungen hat und dafür werden 10 Milliarden im nächsten Jahr kreditfinanziert bereitgestellt. Also insofern hat die FDP, die sagt ja immer, Schulden schaffen keine Zukunft. Bei der Rente hat sie da offensichtlich eine andere Meinung und dieser Meinung sind wir dann testhalber gefolgt.
Also wie war noch mal diese Regel nach 29 allen Wirtschaftskrisen durch die Bank, nicht auf Pumpaktien kaufen? So war das.
Ich glaube ja und ich denke jetzt auch gerade an diese Zinslast, die ja kommt, wenn man 10 Milliarden aufnimmt. Und jetzt will man aber diese 10 Milliarden. Ja Moment, wir haben ja steigende Zinsen. Das ist ja nicht falsch. Das ist nicht falsch, dass wir die haben. So, jetzt ist aber die Rechnung von Lindner. Wir nehmen 10 Milliarden auf. Wollen aber eigentlich ja nicht, weil wir ja diese Zinslast so dran haben. Nehmen diese 10 Milliarden aber auf, um Zinseszinsgewinne zu bekommen an der Börse. Und die investieren wir dann. Aber natürlich wird diese Zinseszins stark angefressen. Dadurch, dass ja diese 10 Milliarden abgetragen werden müssen. Das heißt, die Rendite dürfte sehr gering ausfallen, wenn sich die Börse nicht unglaublich nach vorne schiebt.
Ich finde es gut, solche Geschäfte über Hebel zu organisieren, dass man sich einen Zinseszins verspricht, mit dem man dann die Zinsschuld abträgt und so. Sowas klappt dann auch besonders gut. Bei, das sieht man ja gerade in der Schweiz und so weiter, wenn über Nacht irgendwelche Banken enteignet werden müssen, die, ach so, die haben eine 200-jährige Geschichte, na egal, muss jetzt mal schnell abgeräumt werden, bevor in Asien die Erdmarkte auch noch...
Zwei Milliarden, also da dachte ich mir, da hätten ja auch hier die eine oder andere zuschlagen können. Hier in Frankfurt wäre das so sicherlich zwei Milliarden, oder? Da baut man so ein, was ist das? Eine Dreizimmerwohnung oder was bringt man dafür hier her?
Also ein Stockwerk irgendwo.
Aber ich meine, man muss es noch einmal herausarbeiten, Lindner ist eine Katastrophe und ich erwarte eigentlich den Koalitionsbruch oder die Androhung des Koalitionsbruchs. Ich meine, Habeck redet doch schon die ganze Zeit so, als hätte er vor einer halben Minute geweint. Also deswegen müsste man doch jetzt da mal was tun.
Kommt aus der Kabinettsklausur, alles super. Also wir enden mit einem Sinnspruch von Christian Lindner. Er erklärt uns jetzt noch einmal seine ganze politische Persönlichkeit. Das ist dann auch der...
Das ist vielleicht der Sinnspruch, den auch Lars Amand hätte machen können.
Genau, es ist dann auch der letzte Clip für heute, denn danach kann aber nichts mehr kommen.
Ich mache Politik zunächst einmal aus Überzeugung und nicht wegen des Applauses des Tages, sondern auf der langen Strecke zeigt sich, ob jemand eine innere Haltung hat oder nicht. Wer sich jeden Tag an Umfragen, Twitter-Trends oder Applaus orientiert, ist aus meiner Überzeugung heraus verloren.
Eitelkeit ist diesem Manne fremd, das wissen wir.
Absolut.
So wird die Geschichte ihm wahrscheinlich nicht recht geben. Wir werden sehen. Aber es war ein wunderbarer Abend. Vielen Dank. Wir sagen noch hier schon mal intern, dass wir das nächste Mal auf dem liberalen Pfad im Salon weitergehen, denn wir werden über das Bitcoin-Buch von Ijoma Mangold sprechen. Ich glaube, als wir ja damals dieses Interview besprachen, haben wir gesagt, also dieses Buch werden wir nicht lesen. Aber wir sind jetzt doch getriggert und werden uns das vornehmen und vieles Weitere dann. Vielen Dank, dass ihr alle gekommen seid. Jetzt kommen wir zur Abschlussmusik.